COMMITTEE FOR TUESDAY MARCH.
TWENTY SIX WE ARE A LITTLE BIT
AFTER NINE AM.
I BELIEVE WE HAVE A QUORUM.
IF YOU COULD CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE HERE GALLAGHER.
CHAO.
CHIU GONZALEZ [inaudible]
HOLDEN KALRA.
FONG MAIN CHECK [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
NORRIS [inaudible]
REYES.
OKAY WE DO HAVE A QUORUM WE ARE
WAITING FOR AUTHORS ANDERSON WAS
FRIEDMAN IS CLOSE -- WOULD
HOPEFULLY WE CAN TAKE THAT ONE
UP -- TAKE A MOTION ON THE
CONSENT AGENDA UNLESS ANYONE
WOULD LIKE TO PULL AN ITEM.
FROM CONSENT.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION.
AND A SECOND ON THE CONSENT
AGENDA CALL THE ROLL PLEASE
STONE.
BY STONE AYE GALLAGHER CHOW.
CHOW I CHIU GONZALEZ.
CONSULT AYE HOLDEN KALRA -- I
FONG.
MAIENSCHEIN.
HI MAIENSCHEIN I OBERNOLTE
OBERNOLTE I PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS I REYES.
THOSE BILLS ARE OUT THAT IS AB
FIVE FIFTY EIGHT PETRIE-NORRIS
AB SIX TWENTY TWO CHEN.
AB SIX SEVENTY SEVEN CHOI A. B.
SIX NINETY TWO MAIENSCHEIN AB
EIGHT HUNDRED CHIU AB EIGHT
TWENTY EIGHT TING.
AB EIGHT FIFTY NINE MAIENSCHEIN
AB EIGHT SIXTY ONE CHEN AB NINE
TWENTY FIVE GLORIA AB NINE
NINETY ONE GALLAGHER.
AND AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY FIVE BY
BAUER-KAHAN.
I WILL ALSO NOTE FOR THE RECORD
THAT VINCE FONG WILL BE JOINING
US IN PLACE OF MISTER KILEY
TODAY FOR OUR HEARING.
IF WE COULD GET.
OUR AUTHORS.
WE COULD GET ROLLING
OKAY AS WE
WAIT ON OTHER AUTHORS WE'RE
GONNA GO GO TO ITEM NUMBER FOUR
EIGHTY SIX SIXTY EIGHT MS
GONZALEZ.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
GOOD MORNING.
AB SIX SIXTY EIGHT WOULD PROTECT
IMMIGRANTS IN ALL CALIFORNIANS
FROM CIVIL REST AT A COURTHOUSE
WHEN THE INDIVIDUAL IS ATTENDING
A COURT PROCEEDING OR HAS LEGAL
BUSINESS IN THE COURTHOUSE.
THE ENGLISH COMMON LAW PRIVILEGE
FROM ARREST DATES BACK TO AT
LEAST THE FOURTEENTH CENTURY
WELL COMMON LAW PRIVILEGE FROM
ARREST HAS A LONG HISTORY IN
BOTH ENGLAND AND THE UNITED
STATES IT HAS FALLEN OUT OF USE
IN MODERN LAW.
LARGELY BECAUSE CIVIL RESTED
BECOME LESS COMMON.
AS A RESULT FAMILIARITY WITH THE
COMMON LAW PRIVILEGE AGAINST
CIVIL RIGHTS HAS FADED AMONG
LEGAL PRACTITIONERS AND JUDGES.
ALTHOUGH TRADITIONAL CIVIL REST
MAY HAVE DECLINE THEY HAVE NOT
ENTIRELY DISAPPEARED TRUST
BETWEEN STATE AND LOCAL AGENCIES
THE COMMUNITIES THEY SERVE AS
CRUCIAL. TO THE ENFORCEMENT OF
LAWS THAT KEEP CALIFORNIA'S SAFE.
ABOUT ONE IN FOR CALIFORNIANS IS
AN IMMIGRANT ACCORDING TO TWENTY
SIXTEEN ESTIMATE BY THE PUBLIC
POLICY INSTITUTE OF CALIFORNIA.
IN THE CURRENT CLIMATE OF XENA
PHOBIA FROM THE FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION T IS A MORE
CRITICAL THAT ARE IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES HAVE A RELATIONSHIP
OF TRUST WITH INSTITUTIONS AND
SERVICE PROVIDERS.
FEAR WITHIN THE IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITY INCREASES WHEN STATE
LOCAL AGENCIES ARE ENTANGLED
WITH FEDERAL IN IMMIGRATION
ENFORCEMENT.
THIS MAY RESULT HESITANCY BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO INTERACT
WITH STATE AGENCIES AND CLAIM
EARNED BENEFITS OR REPORT
VIOLATIONS OF STATE LAWS AND
REGULATIONS.
CALIFORNIA MUST PROTECT AN
INDIVIDUAL'S RIGHT TO VISIT THE
COURTS AND PARTICIPATE COURT
PROCEEDINGS WITHOUT FEAR OF
ARREST.
NOTHING IN THIS BILL WILL
PREVENT A LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER FOR MAKING A CRIMINAL
REST IN A COURTHOUSE IF THERE IS
PROBABLE CAUSE THAT THE TARGET A
PERSON COMMITTED A CRIME WHAT
THE ARRESTING OFFICER WITNESS
CRIMINAL CONDUCT.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO REMOVE THE
THREAT OF CIVIL REST AT THE
COURTHOUSE TO ENCOURAGE MEMBERS
OF THE IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY TO
ENGAGE IN PARTICIPATING COURT
PROCEEDINGS WHICH SERVES THE
PUBLIC INTEREST OF CALIFORNIANS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NINE
ABOUT.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND FIRST WITNESS
PLEASE.
CHRIS RESPONSE WHICH OF THE
COALITION FOR HUMANE MMIGRANT
RIGHTS PROBABLY BE A SPONSOR
THIS MEASURE WHAT CHIRLA HAS THE
DEPORTATION DEFENSE UNIT LEGAL
SERVICE UNIT IN ADDITION TO
HAVING A ONE EIGHT HUNDRED
NUMBER.
WHICH THROUGHOUT THE YEARS SINCE
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION --
ASSAD HAS BEEN IN OFFICE OUR
MANY OF OUR COMMUNITIES HAVE
CALLED AT ONE EIGHT HUNDRED
NUMBER ASKING FOR SUPPORT
SYSTEMS TO GO.
ON WITH HIM TO COURT AND
SPECIFICALLY JUST.
TO PAY FOR A PARKING TICKET ARE
TO GO TO A HEARING FOR THEIR
LOVED ONES -- IT'S SO THERE IS
FEAR LAST YEAR WE SEEN ABOUT
THREE ARRESTS ARE IN COURT
HOUSES HERE AND ARE CALIFORNIA
WHAT SPECIFICALLY YOU'RE IN
SACRAMENTO WHICH DID HAVE A A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES.
THEREFORE THAT'S WHY WE ARE OP
PRADA SPONSOR THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU THAT'S WHAT THIS ONE
IS SHERMAN ALBERTO TRICK ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
APPLICANT ATTORNEY ASSOCIATION
ALSO CORRESPONDS TO THE MEASURE.
ONE OF THANK THE THE AUTHOR AS
WELL AS THE WHICH MISTER
CHAIRMAN YOUR STAFF.
I DON'T WANNA REPEATING THE I'M
SURE OF DOCTORS COVERED THE BILL
BUT AS I REPRESENT TOPPING
ATTORNEYS WE HAVE THE WE
REPRESENT THE MOST IMMIGRANTS IN
CALIFORNIA OF ANY ASSOCIATION.
AN ARCTIC SPURS OF OUR TURNS
BEEN SIMILAR TO WHAT'S BEEN SAID
TODAY THAT.
THERE IS A GREAT -- FEAR FACTOR
THERE ISN'T GREAT TREPIDATION
FROM PEOPLE GOING TO COURT AND
AND TESTIFYING IN OPEN
PROCEEDINGS WHETHER CIVIL OR
CRIMINAL CASES SO WE THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT MEASURE.
TO BRING ABOUT SOME SENSE OF
CONFIDENCE FOR IMMIGRANTS THAT --
ONE REDEEM THE RIGHTS RESPECT
FASHIONABLE.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT IF YOU
COULD GIVE US YOUR NAME AND YOUR
AFFILIATION PLEASE.
WE HANG ON A SECOND LET'S GET
THE MICROPHONE ON ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU NOW TRY CHRISTINE
SMITH CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIPS
AND THE MYSTIC VIOLENCE IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MARIE CLEAR JAR WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PLAN MILLERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
SHANE GUSMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS IN SUPPORT.
AND MY MATHIS ON ME OF UT W.
ASKED ME LOCAL THIRTY NINE
THIRTY IN SUPPORT.
IT'S NOT YOUR HERNANDEZ ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS
FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND SUPPORT
THE BILL.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT SEE NONE IS THEIR
OPPOSITION.
RIGHT SIGNAL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE QUESTION COMMENTS.
HELLO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD OUR CHIEF JUSTICES
EVEN WEIGHED IN ON THIS TRYING
TO PROTECT PEOPLE AND ACCESS TO
THE COURTS AND THE APPROPRIATE
ADMINISTRATION OF JUSTICE I
THINK THIS IS IN ALL OF OUR
INTERESTS.
THE RESULTS YOU MAKE OUT.
THANK YOU OF WE DO HAVE A SORRY
I MISSED THAT WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE STONE HI
STONE AYE GALLAGHER.
CHOW.
CHOW I CHIU.
SALAS.
CONSULT AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA.
CALLER I FONG.
FONG NO MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I OBERNOLTE.
OPEN AS SHE NOTE PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS HI RES.
THAT BILL IS OUT THANK YOU WE'RE
NOT GOING TO MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER
ONE AB FORTY FOUR THIS FRIEDMAN
WELCOME.
THANK YOU CHAIR STONE A MEMBERS.
TO BEGIN I'D LIKE TO ACCEPT THE
THREE PROPOSED COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS THE ANALYSIS
INCLUDING.
PAGE EIGHT REGARDING FEDERAL
PREEMPTION PAGE NINE MOVING THE
EFFECTIVE DATE OF THE BILL BACK
A YEAR. TO JANUARY TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY ONE AND PAGE ELEVEN
ADDING TRADITIONAL BEFORE TRIBAL
CULTURAL AND SPIRITUAL PURPOSES.
AB FORTY FOUR WOULD MAKE IT
UNLAWFUL TO SELLER MANUFACTURE A
NEW FOR PRODUCT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
IF PASSED CALIFORNIA WILL BE THE
FIRST IN THECOUNTRY TO BAN THE
CRUEL AND UNNECESSARY FOR TRADE
WITHIN ITS BORDERS. FOR IS NOT A
BY PRODUCT OF THE MEAT INDUSTRY
IT COMES FROM ANIMALS AT OUR
FACTORY FARMED OR TRAPPED IN THE
WHILE PURELY FOR FASHION. FOR
FARMING AND THE FUR TRADE ARE
LARGELY SELF REGULATED.
IN THE U. S. THERE ARE NO
FEDERAL LAWS FOR PROVIDING
PROTECTION FOR ANIMALS HELD ON
THESE FARMS AND FERBER ANIMALS
ARE NOT SUBJECT TO HUMANE
SLAUGHTER RULES.
TODAY THERE ARE A VARIETY OF
HUMANE ALTERNATIVES BOTH IN
TERMS OF PHùFOR THAT IS
VIRTUALLY INDISTINGUISHABLE FROM
REAL FOR AN ALTERNATIVE TEXTURE
TEXTILES THAT ARE JUST AS WARMER
FASHIONABLE AND A LOT MORE FUN.
COMPANIES AROUND THE WORLD ARE
FUELING INNOVATION AND NEW AND
SUSTAINABLE FABRICS RETAILERS
SUCH AS GUCCI MICHAEL CORES
JIMMY CHOO ARMANI BURBERRY AND
SHOULD NOW HAVE MADE THE
DECISION TO GO FOR FREE AS HAVE
MANY OTHERS.
SEVERAL CITIES INCLUDING LOS
ANGELES SAN FRANCISCO WEST
HOLLYWOOD AND BERKELEY HAVE
ALREADY TAKEN A STAND BY PASSING
ORDINANCES MAKING IT ILLEGAL TO
SELL TRADE OR MANUFACTURE FOR
WITHIN THEIR BOUNDARIES.
THERE'S NO REASON FOR CALIFORNIA
TO CONTINUE TO PARTAKE IN AN
INDUSTRY THAT PUTS ANIMALS
THROUGH SUCH SUFFERING FOR
NONESSENTIAL MEANS AND JUST TO
BE CLEAR OUT OUR BILL DOES NOT
AFFECT LEATHER.
IT DOES NOT AFFECT IN -- FOR A
THAT IS A BY PRODUCT OF ME
PRODUCTION GO TO CAL.
A AND SHEEP SO THOSE FOR
PRODUCTS WILL STILL BE ALLOWABLE
UNDER THE BILL.
WHICH IT AB IS SUPPORTED BY THE
GAP HUGO BOSS PATAGONIA RETAILER
H. AND M. STELLA MCCARTNEY SUSIE
AND JACK WELCH MERRICK ERIC
GARCETTI AND OVER SIXTY OTHER
DESIGNERS RETAILERS AND
ORGANIZATIONS.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB FORTY FOUR IS PJ
SMITH WITH THE HUMANE SOCIETY
AND MARK CHING FOUNDER OF ANIMAL
HOPING LEGISLATION.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE THANK THANK YOU THE FIRST
WITNESS PLEASE.
THANK YOU SIMPLIFICATION AND
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN MY
NAME IS PJ SMITH AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF FASHION POLICY FOR
THE HUMANE SOCIETY OF THE UNITED
STATES A PROUD COAST BOUNDS.
COSPONSORED AB.
FORTY FOUR ON BEHALF OF THE
HUMANE SOCIETY OF NIGHT STATES
IN OUR SUPPORTERS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA WE URGE YOU TO VOTE
YES ON HIS HIS WHOLE HISTORIC
BILL. FOR A DECADE I'VE WORKED
WITH BRANDS AND DESIGNERS FROM
PUCCI MICHAEL CORES AND CHANEL'S
TO TJ TO TJ MAX TO CREATE
POLICIES.
HELPANIMALS AND THE ENVIRONMENT.
WHEN THESE COMPANIES EXAM I'M IN
THE FUR TRADE EVERYDAY CLAIM
EVERY CERTIFICATION SCHEME THEY
QUICKLY REALIZE THERE'S NO WAY
TO HUMANELY SOURCE?
FOR THAT'S WHY SO MANY OF THESE
COMPANIES ARE NOW GOING FOR FREE.
AS CONSUMER AWARENESS GROWS THE
FUR INDUSTRY CONTINUES TO ROLL
OUT INDUSTRY FUNDED MARKETING
SCHEMES TO GREEN WASH ITS TRADE.
THE LATEST IS CALLED FOR MARK
BUT NO MATTER WHAT THEY CALL IT
EVERY TIME HIS FAILED TO ADDRESS
EVEN THE MOST SERIOUS ANIMAL
WELFARE CONCERNS.
UNDER FOR MARKING SIMILAR
SCHEMES WILD ANIMALS ARE STILL
CRAMMED IN BEARING CAGES FOR
THEIR ENTIRE LIFE.
THEY'RE STILL CAUGHT LEG HOLD
TRAPS FOR DAYS WITHOUT FOOD
WATER AND THEY STILL DIE BY
ELECTROCUTION THE LIST GOES ON
AND NUMEROUS INVESTIGATIONS OF
THE SHOW THAT CERTIFIED FARMS
ARE STILL RANT THAT WAS SELF
MUTILATION AND OTHERS BEHAVIORS
THAT ARE CAUSED BY STRESS AND
FEAR.
THE FUR INDUSTRY COULD CHOOSES
TO CREATE SMOKE STREET YOU SMOKE
SCREENS RATHER THAN PREPARE FOR
CONSUMERS CHANGING CHECK TAKES.
IN FACT JUST LAST YEAR WHEN
INTERNATIONAL FOR FEDERATION WAS
TRYING TO PROMOTE FOR AS ETHICAL
ECOLOGICAL FRANCES INDEPENDENT
ADVERTISING AUTHORITY CALL THOSE
CLAIMS MISLEADING AND ABUSIVE IN
EVEN BASED ON LIES.
THE THIRTIES ALSO SAID NUMEROUS
RELIABLE REPORTS SHOW THAT THE
PRODUCTION OF FOR IS EXTREMELY
CRUEL INCLUDING IN THAT THE
FINAL PRODUCT CONTAINS TOXIC
SUBSTANCES.
TODAY'S CONSUMERS ESPECIALLY IN
CALIFORNIA CARE ABOUT ANIMAL
WELFARE THE ENVIRONMENT AND
INNOVATION MORE THAN EVER IN
FASHION BRANDS ARE RESPONDING BY
ANNOUNCING FOR FREE POLICIES.
AND DEVELOPING SUSTAINABLE
MATERIALS THEY HAVE THE SAME
LOOK AND FEEL AS FOR WITHOUT THE
CRUELTY ENVIRONMENTAL
DEGRADATION.
THIS IDEA RESONATES WITH
CONSUMERS AND THROUGHOUT THE
FASHION WORLD AND NOW CALIFORNIA
CAN CAPITALIZE ON THE GROWING
MARKET WITH THE PASSAGE OF AB
FORTY FOUR CALIFORNIA WILL
SOLIDIFY ITS POSITION AS THE
NATION'S MOST INNOVATIVE AND
HUMANE STATE.
AND WE URGE YOU TO VOTE YES
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THAT'S WHAT PLEASE.
HI MY NAME IS MARCHING I'M FROM
A GROUP CALLED ANIMAL OPEN
LEGISLACIóN -- PART OF OUR
HISTORY AS A GROUP IS WE'VE GONE
ON THE COVER IN TWO DIFFERENT
FACTORIES AND SLAUGHTER HOUSES
AND FOR FARMS ACROSS THE US AND
CANADA AND CHINA IN DIFFERENT
COUNTRIES.
THOSE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
THE CLAIM THAT MUCH OF THE VIDEO
SEEN ON SOCIAL MEDIA ARE
FABRICATED OR OUTDATED AN OLD.
AND BASED ON THAT FACT IS A
MISREPRESENTATION TO THE FOR
INDUSTRY.
WHY WERE SO PASSIONATE IS
BECAUSE I'VE BEEN THERE MYSELF
I'VE BEEN INTO FOR FARMS AND
CHINA FINLAND WHICH IS -- NUMBER
TWO EXPORTER -- FOR IN THE
UNITED STATES AND CANADA AS WELL.
AND I CAN TELL YOU THERE IS NO
STANDARD THERE IS NO HUMANE WAY.
TO SKIN A FOX.
A MANY OF THESE FOXES ARE
ELECTROCUTED IN STUNNED.
SOME BEAT IN THE HEAD.
I'VE SEEN THE CAGES THAT THE
BREAD INTO AND LIVE THEIR WHOLE
ENTIRE LIVES NEVER TOUCHING
GROUND.
I'VE WATCHED THEM.
KILL THEM IN MASSES -- WHEN I
WAS IN CHINA IN THIS PLACE
CALLED HE BAY WHICH IS?
A HUGE EXPORTED TO THE US.
FOR FOR THERE WAS A BUYER FROM
NEW YORK THERE.
AND IN A MATTER OF MAYBE TEN
MINUTES IT KILLED FIVE THOUSAND
FOXES.
AND THEY PUT THEM IN THESE PILES.
THESE FOXES THEY DON'T USE THE
MEAT THEY REYES ONLY FURTHER
SCANS.
AT THE END WHEN THEY STARTED TO
PREPARE THEM TO RIP YOUR SKIN
OFF YOU COULD HEAR THEM
SCREAMING.
AND WHILE IT'S NOT INTENTIONAL
FOR THEM TO BE ALIVE MANY OF
THEM STILL WERE -- WE'VE TAKEN
VIDEOS AND WE'VE SHARE THESE
WITH MEMBERS OF VAST WE'VE.
I USED IT IN LOS ANGELES WHERE
WE BAN FOR AS WELL.
THEY TALK ABOUT.
HAVING A STANDARD BUT WHEN IT
COMES TO CRUELTY SEEM LIKE THAT
THERE'S NO WAY YOU CAN REGULATE
A TYPE OF INDUSTRY.
THAT INVOLVES SUCH IN HUMANE AND
CRUEL METHODS.
AND WE ASK FOR YES VOTE BASED ON
THE FACT THAT.
COMPASSION ESPECIALLY IN OUR
STATE.
HAS TO COME FIRST SO I THINK WE
AS CALIFORNIANS ARE PROGRESSIVE
AND WERE ETHICAL AND THE
CONSUMERS ARE ASKING FOR CHANGE.
AND I THINK.
IT'S TIME AND WE ARE READY AS A
PEOPLE AND I HOPE YOU WILL
CONSIDER THAT.
AND THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND.
RIGHT ANYONE ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE.
TO SUPPORT THE BILL IF YOU COULD
COME FORWARD AND GIVE US YOUR
NAME AND YOUR AFFILIATION PLEASE.
SCUM THE MICROPHONE.
NAME AND AFFILIATION PLEASE
CRYSTAL MARLON REPRESENTING THE
HUMANE SOCIETY OF THE UNITED
STATES RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
ASHLEY LUIS REPRESENTING PIZZA
SUPPORT OF AB.
FORTY FOUR THANK YOU MR MAT
ROBINSON ON BEHALF OF LOS
ANGELES MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI IN
SUPPORT.
SAY IT ISN'T FROM SAN JOSE
MICHAEL GOLDBERG BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA.
I'M WITH COMPASSIONATE BAY AND I
SUPPORT.
MIKE SAGE SANTA CLARA SUPPORT.
ME ARM LIES OF SANTA CLARA
COUNTY ANIMAL ACTIVISTS FOR
ANIMALS.
IN SUPPORT.
WHEN THE BRAMBLE FROM SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING
ANONYMOUS FOR THE VOICELESS AND
DIRECT ACTION ABRIR I SUPPORT?
SONJI THIS MONDAY FROM DALY CITY
CALIFORNIA WELL INTO THE DIRECT
ACTION OF DO THAT IN SUPPORT.
KIANA JONES FROM BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING DIRECT
ACTION EVERYWHERE SUPPORT.
DEBBIE A CAMARO FROM SACRAMENTO
SUPPORT.
AMIR TANNER FROM SAN JOSE WITH
DIRECT ACTION EVERYWHERE AND I
SUPPORT.
THOMAS JANE FROM SAN FRANCISCO
REPRESENTING DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE AND ANOMALOUS
REQUESTS IN SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS DAN CHAU I'M FROM OUT
NEW CALIFORNIA I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
WHEN SHOWN ONE OF THE CO
FOUNDERS A DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL AND WITH THE MILLIONS A
CALIFORNIANS WHO ALSO SUPPORT
THIS?
STACEY PLACATED SAN DIEGO I
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
DIANNE ANY VON WITH DIRECT
ACTION EVERYWHERE I'M FROM
BERKELEY STRONGLY SUPPORT.
STEPANEK A BRACKETS FROM OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT.
MATTHEW MCKENNA OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY SUPPORT.
AMANDA OXFORD WALNUT CREEK
DILLON HERMAN FROM BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA I'M WITH DIRECT
ACTION EVERYWHERE AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT.
ALONE OF THE MORE ARE FROM THIS
NUMBER COUNTY OUT BUSINESS
COMMUNITY A STRONG SUPPORT.
MUST SUCK WITH GLASS.
I'M FROM A OAKLAND CALIFORNIA
BROWN TO A FULL COMPASSIONATE
BAY EYES SUPPORT.
DILLON HAZEL OFFERS SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY SUPPORT.
SANDY MEL BERKELEY CALIFORNIA
DIRECT ACTION EVERYWHERE I
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
THEN THE MIDDLE SOURCE
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF
OF DIXIE.
PETER AND SACRAMENTO VEGAN
SOCIETY WITH FOUR THOUSAND
MEMBERS I STRONGLY SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS STILL IN WELLS
REPRESENTING ANIMAL LIBERATION
ORGANIZATIONS THAT SUCKS STATE
UNIVERSITY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
EVER CLAUSON ABOUT A CALIFORNIA
I'M HERE FOR MYSELF AND MY
BUDDIES WHO HAVE A WONDERFUL
LIFE I HOPE THAT YOU WILL
PROVIDE THE SAME PER MORE THANK
YOU.
PLEASE SUPPORT.
DEBBIE BUT DEBBIE PUKUL EISEN
FROM PLEASANT HEALTH I STRONGLY
SUPPORT.
LIVE FUNDING REPRESENTING DIRECT
ACTION EVERYWHERE I STRONGLY
SUPPORT AND PLAY SUPPORTIVE.
MARIAM QUALITY FROM BELMONT
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
IN TURN YOU MORE FROM SAN MATTEO
A MEMBER OF DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE AND IN ON THIS FOR
THE VOICELESS AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE BILL.
LESLEY GOLDBERG FROM ELSE RIDEAU
CALIFORNIA -- AND I'M WITH
COMPASSIONATE CITIES AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
GEN CARL MARCELLO'S A FROM SAN
DIEGO CALIFORNIA.
AND I'M HERE RESTRICTED TO
DIRECT ACTION EVERYWHERE I
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS BRIANNA MARTELLO SO
I'M FROM SAN DIEGO -- WITH
DIRECT ACTION EVERYWHERE SAN
DIEGO ANIMAL SAVE SAN DIEGO
VEGAN ACTIVISTS AND WE'RE ALL IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS HANNAH HEY FAIR
AND I'M ON BEHALF OF DIRECT
ACTION EVERYWHERE AND AN OMINOUS
FOR THE VOICELESS.
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
I'M JACKIE LAWRENCE I'M FROM
BERKELEY I'M WITH DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
BUT MARROW THOMAS HERNANDEZ I'M
I'M.
REPRESENTING AN HONEST FOR THE
VOICELESS DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE AND THE ANIMALS.
AND I SUPPORT.
ERIN SKINNER FROM SOUTH LAKE
TAHOE ON BEHALF OF THE NON HUMAN
INDIVIDUALS OF THIS PLANET I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS CHRISTY RENDERED
MARTIN I'M FROM ALBERTA
CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL -- US A BETTER SKATER FROM
SAN CARLOS CALIFORNIA I'M WITH
DIRECT ACTION EVERYWHERE AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
JOHN FROM MEYER FROM BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA AND WITH DIRECT
ACTION EVERYWHERE I STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
YES HIDING FROM DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE.
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL AND
FOR THE MILLIONS OF ANIMALS I'VE
SEEN SUFFER.
I'M VERONICA RAF KIND ON BEHALF
OF ANIMAL HOPING LEGISLATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
J. FITZ GERALD FROM STANISLAUS
COUNTY STRONGLY SUPPORT.
J. QUICKLY FOR BERKELEY
COALITION AND FOR ANIMALS IN
SUPPORT.
ORLANDO TAURUS I SUPPORT THIS
BILL BECAUSE ANIMALS FEEL PAIN
PLANTS DO NOT.
MATTHEW HAMIDI ON BEHALF OF IN
DEFENSE OF ANIMALS AND IT'S OVER
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
MEMBERS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S CASSIE
KING I'M A RESIDENT OF BERKELEY
AND AN INVESTIGATOR WITH DIRECT
ACTION EVERYWHERE.
I'VE BEEN INSIDE OF FARMS AND
SEEN ANIMALS ARE RIGHT UP THERE
THEIR EXPERT TESTIMONY OKAY
COULD YOU SAY THAT YOU SUPPORT.
THANKS.
BUT DOORS FROM MARIN COUNTY --
ON BEHALF IN DEFENSE BONTA MOST
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
JACOBY MARINO OF SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
GARCIA FROM SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THE SETTLEMENT OKAY THANK YOU
ALL FOR BEING HERE I SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
YEAH CALL OR TENNIS WITH
ANONYMOUS FOR VOICE THE SANTA
CLARA COUNTY CHAPTER AND THE XP.
AND IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
JANICE DICKINSON FROM SUNNYVALE
CALIFORNIA I'M WITHIN ARMS FOR
THE VOICELESS SANTA CLARA COUNTY
CHAPTER AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
I'M PULLING WILLOW FROM SAN
FRANCISCO CALIFORNIA.
ANONYMOUS FOR THE VOICES SANTA
CLARA COUNTY CHAPTER AND DIRECT
ACTION EVERYWHERE [inaudible]
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
DANIEL BROUGHT ON BEHALF OF
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
HOLY MICHON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF WEST HOLLYWOOD IN SUPPORT.
SENDER LOCAL SACRAMENTO SUPPORT.
ALICIA SAN TORIO FROM SAN
FRANCISCO CALIFORNIA DIRECT
ACTION EVERYWHERE IN THE SAVE
MOVEMENT I SUPPORT THE BILL.
MY NAME IS MATTHEW THEM SKIN I'M
FROM SAN FRANCISCO AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL AS WELL THANK YOU.
PAULA CENTURION FROM FAIRFIELD
CALIFORNIA IN HONOR OF MY
RESCUED BY NEEDS SALIM.
TWIGGY DICKENS I SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
I LIKE SOME TO RIO FOR FEEL
CALIFORNIA I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING I'M JASON DAVIS
FROM FALLS IN CALIFORNIA I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THAT IT BUT THE SECOND WAS CITED
FROM BERKELEY CALIFORNIA AN
ORGANIZER WITH DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
DUGGAR FULLER BERKELEY DIRECT
ACTION EVERYWHERE IN SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS ANASTASIA MEL I'M AN
ORGANIZER WITH BERKELEY CHAPTER
OF ANONYMOUS FOR THE VOICELESS
AND DIRECT ACTION EVERYWHERE.
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
REACH OF THE GLARE FROM BERKELEY
WITH DIRECT ACTION EVERYWHERE I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
I'M PAUL DURENBERGER SUMMER FROM
BERKELEY CALIFORNIA WITH DIRECT
ACTION EVERYWHERE IN THE BIRTH
IN RIGHT CENTER AND SPORTS BILL
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
[inaudible] ONE MORE.
ALL RIGHT SEEING NONE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION.
NICOLE SMITH FROM SERGIO THE
TAPES IF YOU LIKE AND GIVE
TESTIMONY.
I'LL TAKE
.
THREE THE MORNING GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS BUT SALAS STERN OF
KELLY DRIVE MORE AN LP.
DRIVE REPRESENTS THE
INTERNATIONAL FOR FEDERATION FOR
COMMISSION USA AND THE FUR
INFORMATION COUNCIL OF AMERICA.
I'M HERE TO EXPLAIN WHY AB FORTY
FOUR IS UNCONSTITUTIONAL FIRST
AND FOREMOST AB FORTY FOUR
IMPOSES A CLEAR VIOLATION OF THE
FIRST AMENDMENT ESTABLISHMENT
CLAUSE THE SUPREME COURT IN THE
MOVIE CRESSMAN.
EXPLAINED THAT FOR A LOT TO NOT
RUN AFOUL OF THE ESTABLISHMENT
CLAUSE ITS PRINCIPAL OR PRIMARY
EFFECT MUST BE ONE THAT NEITHER
ADVANCES NOR INHIBITS RELIGION
AND IS THAT YOU MUST NOT FOSTER
AN EXCESSIVE GOVERNMENT
ENTANGLEMENT WITH RELIGION.
BY EXCLUDING FOR PRODUCTS USED
FOR RELIGIOUS PURPOSES FROM ITS
OTHERWISE COMPREHENSIVE BAN ON
YOU FIRST THE LAW UPRIGHT THE
LOTS PRIMARY EFFECT IS TO
ADVANCE RELIGION BY ALLOWING THE
PURCHASE AND USE OF NEW FOR ITS
FOR RELIGIOUS PURPOSES ONLY.
FURTHERMORE BY EXCLUDING
RELIGIOUS FIRST FROM THE BAND AB
FORTY FOUR WILL NECESSARILY
FOSTER AN EXCESSIVE GOVERNMENT
ENTANGLEMENT WITH RELIGION THE
BILL'S LANGUAGE IMPOSES A
RELIGIOUS TEST BEFORE ALLOWING
THE PURCHASE OF A FOR PRODUCTS A
RELIGIOUS TEST WHICH MUST BE
ADMINISTERED BY STATE AGENCIES.
THE SUPREME COURT EXPLAINED IN
HERNANDEZ WE COMMISSIONER THAT
PERVASIVE MONITORING FOR THE
SUBTLE OR OVERT PRESENTS A
RELIGIOUS MATTER IS A CENTRAL
DANGER AGAINST WHICH WE HAVE
HELD THE ESTABLISHMENT CLAUSE
GUARDS.
SUCH PERVASIVE MONITORING IS
CLEARLY PET PRESENT HERE FOR
THIS REASON ALONE AB FORTY FOUR
IS UNCONSTITUTIONAL BUT THERE
ADDITIONAL REASONS WHY AB FORTY
FOUR DOES NOT PASS
CONSTITUTIONAL MUSTER.
JASMINE SANDERS AN AFRICAN
AMERICAN WRITER RECENTLY
EXPLAINS QUOTE AS SOON AS BLACK
WOMEN COULD AFFORD TO BUY MINK
COATS WHITE SOCIETY IN WHITE
WOMAN SAID FOR WAS ALL WRONG FOR
BOTH AND PASSE.
HE DISTRICT MILLION OUNCES OF AB
FORTY FOUR RELEASED YESTERDAY
UNDERSCORES MISS SANDERS POINTS
THE ANALYSIS STATES THAT THERE
ARE NO CA EQUAL PROTECTION
CONCERNS RELATED TO AFRICAN
AMERICANS BECAUSE AFRICAN
AMERICANS WERE NOT CONSIDERED IN
THE BILL AT ALL BUT THAT IS
EXACTLY THE CONSTITUTIONAL
PROBLEM.
BUT FEELING TICKETS BY FAILING
TO CONSIDER THE NEEDS OF AND THE
IMPACT ON THE AFRICAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY AB FORTY FOUR VIOLATES
THE US CONSTITUTION'S MANDATE OF
EQUAL PROTECTION.
THE SUPREME COURT HAS EXPLAINED
THAT WHEN EQUAL PROTECTION
COUNSELOR JUST LEGISLATION IS
BASED ON RACE AT THIS WILL BE
THE LEGISLATION IS SUBJECT TO
STRICT SCRUTINY AB FORTY FOUR
CANNOT WITHSTAND STRICT SCRUTINY.
AT THE BUILDING NOW CITY
RELEASED YESTERDAY ADMITS AB
FORTY FOUR IS BASED ON
SCATTERSHOT ALLEGATIONS THAT
HAVE NOT BEEN PROVEN IN FACT THE
NOW TO SUBMITTED THAT THE QUOTE
FREQUENCY OF THE PRACTICES
UNQUOTE ALLEGES A QUOTE ON CLEAR.
UNQUOTE AND STATISTICS ABOUT THE
ALLEGED ARMS ARE QUOTE NOT
READILY AVAILABLE ON THESE FACTS
AB FORTY FOUR COULD NOT SURVIVE
AN EQUAL PROTECTION CHALLENGE
THE BILL ALSO PROHIBITS
EXPRESSIVE CONDUCT.
BIKE BY THE CREATORS OF FOR
PRODUCTS BUT THE SUPREME COURT
HAS EXPLAINED THAT THE
CONSTITUTION LOOKS BEYOND THE
WRITTEN OR SPOKEN WORDS AS MEANS
OF EXPRESSION.
AND ANDERSON THE HERMOSA BEACH
THE NINTH CIRCUIT HELD THAT THAT
TO IN ITS PURE PURELY EXPRESSIVE.
ACTIVITY FULLY PROTECTED BY THE
FIRST AMENDMENT APPAREL CREATED
WITH FOR CLOTHING THAT IS MADE
TO BE SOLD AT HIGH END BOUTIQUES
AND AND THROUGHOUT THE STATE
CLEARLY HAS THE SAME FIRST THE
MEMBER PROTECTIONS.
IMPOSING UNIFORM BAN ON THE SALE
OR DISPLAY OF CLOTHING CREATED
WITH FOR VIOLATES THE FIRST
AMENDMENT SUCH LEGISLATION IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL UNDER CLEAR
NINTH CIRCUIT ANSWER PM COURT
PRECEDENT.
DUE TO TIME CONSIDERATIONS I'LL
ADDRESS JUST ONE MORE
CONSTITUTIONAL FACTOR HERE
ALTHOUGH THERE ARE MORE THAT
SHOULD BE CONSIDERED WHEN
RECOGNIZING THE UNCONSTITUTIONAL
NATURE OF AB FORTY FOUR THAT IS
A GERMAN COMMERCE CLAUSE THE
JUDICIAL COMMITTEE THE JUDICIAL
COMMITTEE'S ANALYSIS.
ARGUES THAT THE DORMANT COMMERCE
CLAUSE WOULD NOT BE IMPLICATED
BECAUSE THE LAW IS QUOTE
INDISCRIMINATE ON QUITE AS TO
WHETHER IT IMPACTS IN STATE OR
OUT OF STATE FOR FARMERS
MANUFACTURERS.
BUT THE ANALYSIS ALSO ADMITS
THAT QUOTE FEW IF ANY FOR FIRMS
ARE LOCATED IN CALIFORNIA AND
THAT'S LEGISLATIVE HISTORY OF
THE BILL SHOWS THAT THE BILL
WILL HAVE AN INTENDED EFFECT ON
INTERSTATE COMMERCE.
THIS MAKES AB FORTY FOUR
UNCONSTITUTIONAL AS VIOLATIVE OF
A DORMANT COMMERCE CLAUSE THE
FUR INDUSTRY WHICH IS ALREADY
HIGHLY REGULATED SHARES
CALIFORNIA'S COMMITMENT TO
ETHICAL TREATMENT OF ANIMALS
HOWEVER EIGHTY FORTY FOUR IS NOT
THE APPROPRIATE SOLUTION TO THIS
ISSUE WITH IS UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
THANK YOU.
THAT'S WITH US PLEASE HI THERE
MY NAME IS NICOLE SMITH FROM
STUDIO CITY.
I'M STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THE
SPELL -- AS A STYLIST I
REPRESENT THE VOICES OF HUNDREDS
OF AFRICAN AMERICAN MEN AND
WOMEN WHO CHOOSE FOR AS THE
DISCRETION OF THEIR CULTURAL
HERITAGE -- WE FEEL MARGINALIZED
AND JUST BECAUSE WE CHOOSE FOR
HER WE SHOULD NOT BE PENALIZED
FOR THAT IT IS A LONG HISTORY OF
THE COMMUNITY.
AND I JUST WANTED TO KNOW WHEN
IS THIS MARGINALIZATION GONNA
STOP.
THANK YOU THAT'S WHAT THIS PLACE.
A GOOD MORNING KEEP KAPLAN WITH
FELLOW CALIFORNIA FOR
INFORMATION COUNCIL OF AMERICA
THANK YOU FOR THE CHANCE TO
SPEAK THIS MORNING.
AND HAVE THE FOR INDUSTRY WE
SHARE THE CONCERNS ANIMAL
WELFARE THAT EXPRESSED AN A. B.
FORTY FOUR BUT THE CURRENT
ORDINANCE IS FLAWED.
IT'S BASED ON DECADES OLD FAKE
STUDIES AND VIDEOS THAT HAVE NOW
BEEN PROVEN TO BE STAGED THERE
ARE CARVE OUTS FOR SOME FOR
TYPES AND CERTAIN CULTURAL
GROUPS.
BUT WHAT'S LEFT IS ARBITRARY AND
PERHAPS LEGALLY INDEFENSIBLE.
WE TO WANT TO KEEP BAD PLAYERS
ON THE MARKET.
BUT THE BAND IS NOT THE ANSWER A
BAND SIMPLY SENDS CONSUMERS OUT
OF CALIFORNIA TO PURCHASE FOR
CALIFORNIA LOSES JOBS AND TAX
REVENUES.
AND IN THE END THE BAND HAS
ABSOLUTELY NO IMPACT ON ANIMAL
WELFARE BUT WHAT A BAND DOES DO
IS IT TAKES AWAY THE CONSUMERS
RIGHT TO CHOOSE TO PURCHASE
RENEWABLE SUSTAINABLE PRODUCTS
LIKE NATURAL.
FOR AS OPPOSED TO SYNTHETIC
FIBERS THAT VIOLATE THE VERY
CORE VALUES OF SUSTAINABILITY.
PRODUCTS LIKE FAKE FOR THAT OUR
PETROLEUM BASED NON
BIODEGRADABLE AND POSE AN
ENVIRONMENTAL THREAT SO REAL
THAT EVEN HERE IN YOUR OWN
ASSEMBLY YOU'VE BEEN PRESENTED
WITH A MICROFIBER BILL.
AND AS YOU KNOW THE ANALYSIS THE
CONSUMERS HAVE SPOKEN FIRST
SALES IN THE U. S. INCREASED
OVER 50% BETWEEN NINETEEN NINETY
THREE IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
AND TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE US
MANUFACTURED MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO BILLION
DOLLARS IN FOR PRODUCT.
WE PROVIDED THE AUTHOR OF AB
FORTY FOUR WITH AMENDMENT THAT
WILL ADDRESS ANIMAL WELFARE ON A
GLOBAL SCALE.
IT IMPLEMENTED ME HOLD ON PLEASE
WE GET AT EXCUSE ME THIS IS NOT
THE TIME FOR OTHERS TO WEIGH IN
WE WOULD YOU.
EXCUSE ME.
THANK YOU YOU ARE BEING WELL
AMPLIFIED OKAY THANK YOU.
IT IMPLEMENTS A PROGRAM CALLED
FOR MARK A CERTIFICATION PROGRAM
GUARANTEES HIGH STANDARDS OF
ANIMAL WELFARE AND
SUSTAINABILITY PERFORMED IN WILD
FOR SOLD IN CALIFORNIA.
IT IS THIRD PARTY MONITORED AND
USES THE LATEST IN BLOCKCHAIN
TECHNOLOGY TO ENSURE
TRACEABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY.
CALIFORNIA COULD TAKE A
LEADERSHIP POSITION LAUNCHING
FOR MARK TO ENSURE MANDATORY
COMPLIANCE AS IT SPREADS ACROSS
THE U. S. IT WILL HAVE A GLOBAL
IMPACT ON ANIMAL WELFARE.
CREATING A TEMPLATE FOR ALL
ANIMAL USE INDUSTRIES TO FOLLOW.
IN DISCUSSIONS ON CANNABIS I'VE
HEARD SOME OF YOU CLAIM THAT THE
BEST WAY TO PREVENT BAD PLAYERS
AN ILLICIT MARKETS IS TO
LEGALIZE AND REGULATE.
THAT SAME RULE APPLIES IN THIS
CASE.
I URGE YOU TO OPPOSE AB FORTY
FOUR IN ITS PRESENT FORMAT.
BANDS ARE NOT PROGRESSIVE BANDS
ARE LAZY LET'S WORK TOGETHER TO
CREATE A BILL THAT WILL IMPROVE
ANIMAL WELFARE AND IMPACTFUL AND
MEANINGFUL WAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION IF YOU
AFFILIATION PLEASE TELL US ALL
THE ON ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
GRAND VIEW DECISION ONE OF THANK
THE THE STAFF OF THE COMMITTEE
STAFF ARE WORKING. TO GET THE
AMENDMENTS THAT I UNDERSTAND ARE
BEING TAKEN.
ON OFF OF LIKE MARKET ANIMALS
THAT ARE BEING RAISED FOR MEAT
AS OFFERS A BY PRODUCT SO I
UNDERSTAND LIKE RABBITS.
THAT'S BEING ADDRESSED TODAY SO
I WANT TO THANK THAT BUT I DO
WANT TO QUESTION.
THAT'S NOT BEING ADDRESSED AND
I'M SORRY WE'RE NOT TAKING
FURTHER TESTIMONY YOU CAN JUST
GIVE US YOUR POSITION ON THE
BILL PLEASE WELL IF THAT'S IN
THERE THEN WE APPRECIATE THAT
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO LOOK AT
THE BILL AND SEE.
AS POSITIONS PROGRESS THANK YOU
AND THAT AMENDMENT IS NOT IN THE
BILL AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MATT GRAHAM BEHALF OF TAXPAYERS
FOR IMPROVING PUBLIC SAFETY AND
ALSO CAL SMALL BUSINESS
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SO LET ME CLARIFY THEN SO THAT
BILLS AND THAT IS NOT BEING
TAKEN.
AT NIGHT OKAY SO STE AT THIS
POINT.
CORRECT OKAY SO SORRY I GOT
MISCOMMUNICATION STAFF THEN WE
PUT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GREG'S 	C INTER CALIFORNIA I
OPPOSE.
THANK YOU.
JASON WRESTLER ON BEHALF OF THE
THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY FAMILY
OWNED MAKE FARMS IN THE UNITED
STATES WE OPPOSE.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT SIGNAL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS MR HOLD.
MORE BURKE FOR A COMMENT I I
SUPPORT THE BILL.
OF AND I MUST SAY THAT THE THE
TESTIMONY OF THE THREE OF YOU
HAVE BEEN VERY -- WILL ISSUE AND
QUITE FRANKLY YOU -- ARE RATHER
INSULTING -- TO SUGGEST THAT
THERE'S A LITTLE CULTURAL
CONNECTION TO THIS ISSUE --
TRIVIALIZES THE POINT.
OF AND IT.
FOCUSES ON A DIVISIVE.
OF ISSUE THAT IS.
NOT ACCEPTED BY ME.
AND IF YOU'RE GOING TO MAKE YOUR
POINT MAKE IT ON A FACTUAL BASIS
THAT.
CAN OF THIS WAS WHAT YOU WOULD
CONSIDER FACTUAL OF THAT IT DOES
NOT SO WITH ME AND IT DOESN'T
SELL WITH AFRICAN AMERICANS THAT
I KNOW.
AND TO USE IT IN THE WAY THAT
YOU HAD I'M SURE THERE WERE
OTHER ARGUMENTS THAT YOU COULD
HAVE MADE.
BUT TO CHOOSE -- TO MAKE IT IN
THE WAY THAT YOU MADE I THINK
WAS NOT HELPFUL TO YOUR CAUSE.
AND QUITE FRANKLY INSULTING TO
THE FOR THE THE PEOPLE THAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO USE TO MAKE
YOUR POINT.
SIDES I REJECT THE YOUR
TESTIMONY I REJECT YOURS.
OTHER MISTER KALRA.
I SO I THINK THE AUTHOR
RESEARCHER -- BUT I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR SUMMER FRIEDMAN
I THINK -- MACHINE AND HER STAFF
CLEARLY OF WORKED REALLY HARD --
TO MAKE A EXEMPTIONS THAT ARE
APPROPRIATE ALLOWING CERTAIN
INDUSTRIES -- AS WELL AS THE THE
RELIGIOUS -- OF FAITH BASED
EXEMPTIONS -- END BUT I I THINK --
IT'S BEEN CLEAR THAT THIS SUMMER
FRIEDMAN HAS BEEN WORKING REALLY
HARD TO FOCUS ON THE ISSUE AT
HAND WAIT WHICH IS THE
UNNECESSARY.
CRUELTY -- BECAUSE TO BY -- BY
THE SALE OF FIRM WITHOUT.
INORDINATELY -- IMPACTING OTHER
AREAS INCLUDING.
THE THE THE CERTAIN INDUSTRIES --
WITH THAT -- THAT HAVE RAISED
OBJECTIONS WHEN THE BILL WAS
FIRST INTRODUCED AS BEEN A
NUMBER OF EXEMPTIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN PUT IN THERE I WANT TO
COMMEND.
THE AUTHOR FOR DOING THAT I WANT
TO THANK EVERYONE FOR BEING HERE
AS WELL AS THE CHAIR AND AND THE
THE CHAIR STAFF.
OF FOR THE ACCIDENT REPORT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF
SOMEONE WOMAN FRIEDMAN I'M I'M
ACTUALLY VERY SYMPATHETIC TO
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO HERE.
UP.
YOU KNOW I THINK WE HAVE A
COUPLE OF FUNDAMENTAL IDEAS THAT
OUR INTENTION ON TE ONE HAND WE
ALL WANT -- TO ADVOCATE FOR
HUMANE TREATMENT OF ANIMALS.
ON THE OTHER HAND FOR THOUSANDS
AND THOUSANDS OF YEARS HUMANS
HAVE KILLED ANIMALS FOR THEIR
FLESH.
AND I DON'T THINK ANYONE IS
ADVOCATING HERE THAT WE
COMPLETELY ABANDON THE PRACTICE
OF USING AN ANIMAL PRODUCTS FOR
ANYTHING.
SO WE'RE TRYING TO THREAD THE
NEEDLE.
IN -- AS WE DO WITH THE
CONSUMPTION OF ANIMAL FLESH
WHERE WE HAVE REGULATIONS FOR
HUMANE WAYS TO REAR THESE
ANIMALS AND TO SLAUGHTER THEM --
AND I'M WONDERING WHY YOU DIDN'T
TAKE THAT APPROACH WITH THIS
BILL BECAUSE YOU COULD HAVE
INTRODUCED REGULATIONS ON THE
FOR INDUSTRY ABOUT HOW THE
ANIMALS WERE RAISED AND
SLAUGHTERED AS WE DO.
IN OTHER PARTS OF ANIMAL
HUSBANDRY INSTEAD OF JUST AN
OUTRIGHT BAN.
THANK YOU AND THAT IS A GOOD
QUESTION -- A LOT OF THE FOR
THAT USED INCLUDING COMES FROM
COUNTRIES WHERE IT WOULD BE
IMPOSSIBLE FOR US TO TRACK AND
REGULATE.
AND WE HAVE ENOUGH TROUBLE
TRACKING IN REGULATING.
I'M THE ITEMS THAT ARE CLEARLY A
PUBLIC -- HELD A PUBLIC HEALTH
DANGER THINGS LIKE.
LEAD CONTAMINATION IN CHILDREN'S
TOYS -- AND SO WE SIMPLY DON'T
HAVE THE MANPOWER OR THE STAFF
TO TRY TO REGULATE ITEMS THAT
ARE MADE IN FOREIGN COUNTRIES
YOU KNOW A LOT OF THIS IS.
A LOT OF THESE PRODUCTS COME
FROM ASIA COME FROM EASTERN
EUROPE PLACES THAT YOU KNOW
OFTENTIMES DON'T HAVE -- THE
KIND OF NETWORK THAT WOULD GIVE
US ANY SORT OF COMFORT ABOUT THE
WAY THAT ON THE ANIMALS BEING
RAISED BUT ALSO ONE OTHER THING
WE TALKING ABOUT WILD ANIMALS
THAT ARE USED IN THESE THIS FOR
PRODUCTS.
THESE ARE ANIMALS THAT BY NATURE
THEY'RE NOT DOMESTICATED ANIMALS.
IT'S MY CONTENTION THAT THE WAY
THAT THEY ARE RAISED IN
CAPTIVITY IS BY NATURE CRUEL
BECAUSE THESE ARE ANIMALS THAT
WANT TO ROME THAT WANT TO HUNT
THERE IT'S NOT A COW.
THAT YOU KNOW IS PRETTY HAPPY
HANGING OUT EATING GRASS ALL DAY.
COM THESE ARE ANIMALS THAT BY
BEING CONFINED -- THE DUES DOES
LEAD TO HIGH LEVELS OF STRESS I
MEAN ZOOS GO TO GREAT LENGTHS TO
KEEP THEIR ANIMALS FOR FILLED
JUST BECAUSE EVEN LIMITING THEIR
ROAMING TO THE SMALL AMOUNT OF
SPACE THAT THEY HAVE AN IS DUE --
IS PROBLEMATIC SOMETIMES FOR
SOME OF THE SPECIES SO THESE ARE
ANIMALS THAT I I DON'T THINK
THERE IS A WAY OF RAISING A LOT
OF THESE ANIMALS OF FOX OR MAKE
THAT IS -- THAT'S NOT COOL TO
THE ANIMAL AND THEN WITH BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT FOOD ANIMALS THE
SLAUGHTERS NOT REGULATED -- SO I
JUST THINK THAT -- I BELIEVE
THAT IF CONSUMERS UNDERSTOOD --
THE SUFFERING THAT WENT INTO THE
GARMENTS THEY WOULDN'T WANT TO
TO WEAR THEM AND I DO THINK THAT
THIS IS AN EXPRESSION OF OF
CALIFORNIA VALUES -- AND I THINK
THAT FOR CALIFORNIA TO TAKE THE
STAND AND SAY WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT PRODUCTS THAT ARE SOLD
IN OUR STATE ARE NOT DONE -- ON
THE WITH THE SUFFERING OF
ANIMALS THAT OF OF BEINGS THAT
CAN'T SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES OR
DEFEND THEMSELVES IS VERY MUCH
IN KEEPING WITH WHAT CALIFORNIA
EXPECTS [inaudible]
RIGHT BUT I I UNDERSTAND -- THIS
LET ME POINT OUT THOUGH THAT IN
OTHER INDUSTRIES.
WHERE THE BURDEN OF REGULATING A
PRODUCT OF THE THE PRODUCTION OF
A PRODUCT WOULD BE TOO GREAT?
WE RELY ON CERTIFICATION
STANDARDS FROM OTHER AGENCIES
AND WE JUST REQUIRE THAT
PRODUCTS THAT ARE SOLD HERE MEET
THOSE STANDARDS -- AND AT THE
BURDEN OF PROOF IS ON THE PERSON
WHO SELLS THE PRODUCT TO PROVE
THAT THOSE STANDARDS HAVE BEEN
COMPLIED WITH AND SO I MEAN I
THINK THAT THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
A BETTER WAY OF OF TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH THIS.
I'VE KIND OF A RELATED QUESTION
AND IT -- IT IT GOES TO ONE OF
THE AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
PREFERRED THAT I UNDERSTAND THAT
YOU'RE NOT ACCEPTING AND IT'S A
QUESTION THAT I HAD ALSO WHICH
IS THAT IF.
AN ANIMAL IS BEING RAISED FOR
ITS MEAT.
AND THERE IS A USE FOR ITS.
FOR WHAT IT NOT BE WASTEFUL THAN
TO DISCARD THE MEAT AND SO THESUGGESTION IS MADE THAT THE BILL
SHOULD HAVE CARVE OUT AN
EXCLUSION. FOR FURTHER CALL
FALLS INTO THAT CATEGORY CAN YOU
EXPLAIN WHY THAT'S NOT SOMETHING
THAT YOU'RE WILLING TO ADD TO
THE BILL BUT WE CERTAINLY HAVE
ADDED GOATS AND AND ANIMALS
WHERE THAT'S THE CASE AND THE
THE REALLY THE ISSUES COME
AROUND RABBITS.
AND THE CONCERNED WITH -- THE
SPONSORS OF THE BILL AND FOLKS
ON OUR SIDE IS THAT ARE OURS TWO
FOLD FIRST OF ALL THAT A LOT OF
THE RABBITS WHOSE FOR IS USE ARE
NOT MEET ANIMALS.
THEIR ANIMALS THEIR RABBITS THAT
ARE REYES FOR CERTAIN TYPES OF
FIRST OF THEIR NOT GENERALLY THE
SAME RABBITS AND SECONDLY THAT.
RABBITS WITH THEM SORT OF FLOOD
THE MARKET -- TO REPLACE THE
OTHER TYPES OF FOR AND THAT
AGAIN THEY WOULDN'T BE USING
ANIMALS THAT WERE RAISED FOR
MEAT WE'RE STILL TALKING.
TO KIND OF THE RABBIT INDUSTRY
TO SEE IF THERE IS A WAY OF
CARVING OUT YOU KNOW A NARROW
EXEMPTION FOR RABBITS THAT ARE
CLEARLY AND DEMONSTRABLY HAVE
BEEN RAISED FOR FOOD.
BECAUSE AGAIN IT'S NOT THIS IS
NOT A BILL IT'S INTENDED TO DE
FACTO.
BAND THE EATING OF RABBITS
THAT'S NOT WHAT THIS BILL IS
TRYING TO DO AND I TOTALLY AGREE
THAT IF YOU'RE KILLING THE
ANIMAL FOR FOOD THAT YOU SHOULD
USE EVERY SINGLE BIT OF THAT
ANIMAL.
ON THE FLIP SIDE IS THAT WE
DON'T WANT TO ENCOURAGE THE
KILLING OF ANIMALS JUST FOR
THEIR FOR BECAUSE THAT'S
WASTEFUL AND NOT SUSTAINABLE AND
WE ARE AFRAID THAT THE RABBIT
EXEMPTION WOULD CREATE MORE FROM
MARKET TO DO JUST THAT SO WE ARE
STILL.
I'M IN DISCUSSIONS ON THAT ISSUE
BUT AT THIS MOMENT WE'RE NOT
AMENDING THE BILL -- WITH -- Là
ALLOWING RABBITS.
SO I WOULD ENCOURAGE USE
BUILDINGS FOR HERE TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH -- ALL OF THE
STAKEHOLDERS TO TRY TO GET TO A
PLACE THAT'S MORE OF A MIDDLE
GROUND.
THE PROBLEM IS IS THE BILL
STANDS NOW THERE ARE A LOT OF US
WHO WE ARE PHILOSOPHICALLY WOULD
LIKE TO BE WITH YOU BUT WHEN
WHEN WE'RE NOT MOVING TOWARDS
THE MIDDLE OF MAKES IT AWFULLY
DIFFICULT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU MISTER MAIENSCHEIN.
THANK YOU I I WANNA THANK YOU MS
FREEMAN FOR BRING IN THIS --
BILL PLEASE TO SUPPORT IT --
WORKED ON A NUMBER OF THESE
ISSUES AND I DO THINK THIS IS AN
IN HUMANE PRACTICE -- ESPECIALLY.
WHEN IT'S CONSIDERED THERE'S NOT
A NEED FOR THESE PART THERE'S
THAT THERE'S NOT A -- THIS ISN'T
THE ONLY ARTICLES OF CLOTHING
THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO PEOPLE.
AND I IT IT -- TO TO TO TO
DEMONSTRATE AND NEEDED THAT
OUTWEIGHS THE INHERENT CRUELTY
THAT EXISTS IN THIS INDUSTRY --
ISN'T OCCURRING HERE.
SO -- VERY HAPPY TO SUPPORT A
GLAD YOU'RE GLAD YOU BRING IN AT
AND LOOK FOR THE SPRING ON THE
FLOOR AS WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHERS [inaudible]
TOGETHER.
SO WE HAD THIS BILL AND WATER
PARKS AND WILDLIFE -- WHAT LAST
WEEK LAST WEEK AND SO JUST KIND
OF FOLLOWING UP AND AND I AND
I'VE ACTUALLY LOOK MORE INTO
THIS YOU KNOW SINCE THAT TIME?
AND I THINK IT JUST MAKES ME
MORE SYMPATHETIC WITH THE
OPPOSITION -- BECAUSE AS AS I
LOOKED INTO THIS ACTUALLY A LOT
OF THE FOR COMES FROM ACTUAL FOR
FARMS AND THESE ARE THESE ARE
SMALL FAMILY OWNED FARMS.
WHERE PEOPLE ACTUALLY REYES?
OF THESE ANIMALS TO THEN YOU
KNOW HARVEST THE FOR ESSENTIALLY
IS WHAT THEY DO.
RIGHT AND AND THERE'S NOT MANY
CALIFORNIA.
AND AND MAYBE YOU CAN SPEAK TO
THAT BUT I MEAN MOST SUMMER OUT
OF STATE.
MOST THE MANUFACTURES OF THE
STATE BUT THIS IS A LEGITIMATE
FARMING LIVESTOCK PRACTICE --
THAT'S GOING ON IT'S AND IT IS A
VERY LARGE INDUSTRY I'M NOT
FAMILIAR WITH IT PROBABLY NOT
MANY OF US UP HERE VERY FAMILIAR
WITH IT AT ALL -- WE PROBABLY
NEVER EVEN BEEN TO A FOR FARM.
IF I NEVER IN TALK TO ANY OF
THESE FARMERS RIGHT -- IN THESE
THE SMALL FAMILY OWNED
BUSINESSES THAT NOW A HUGE
MARKET COULD PUT IT IN
CALIFORNIA COULD JUST BE TAKEN
OFF THE MAP I MEAN THAT'S THAT'S
A PRETTY DRASTIC DECISION. TO
MAKE WHEN THERE'S A LOT OF
PEOPLE THAT ARE IMPACTED BY THE
STATE REALLY AREN'T IN THIS ROOM.
THE MADE FOR THE BET THAT MOST
OF THEM LIVE IN OTHER STATES.
WHO MAYBE CAN'T BE IN THIS ROOM
RIGHT NOW YOU KNOW DURING THE
WORK DAY YOU KNOW?
YOU KNOW ALL THESE THINGS SO I
THINK WE HAVE TO TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THESE THINGS YES YOU
DON'T HAVE PERSONAL EXPERIENCE
WITH IT.
BUT US IS.
THOSE OF US AS LEGISLATORS NEED
TO THINK ABOUT HEY WHAT ARE THE
OTHER WHAT ARE OTHER PEOPLE'S
PERSPECTIVES.
WHO WERE IN THIS INDUSTRY OTHER
OTHER PEOPLE WERE IMPACT AND I
THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT WITH THIS
BILL -- BUT SO AS I AS I
UNDERSTAND YOUR ARGUMENT FROM
LAST TIME -- ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN.
IT'S IT IS IN HUMANE. TO RAISE
ANIMALS FOR FOR ONLY.
BUT IT'S NOT IF THERE REYES FOR
FOOD IS THAT RIGHT.
I WOULD SAY IT'S NOT IT'S
BLESSED SUSTAINABLE CERTAINLY.
I MEAN IS IN HUMANE OR I MEAN
THIS THIS IS ABOUT A MORAL
PRINCIPLE OF WERE NOT SOMETHING
TO MAN HER OR NOT RIGHT.
I I THINK THAT THERE'S A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN ANIMALS THAT
FOR GENERATIONS HAVE BEEN
DOMESTICATED AND ADJUST AND DO
WELL IN CAPTIVITY AND THESE
ANIMALS WHICH ARE ARE BY NATURE
WILD ANIMALS BEING KEPT IN SMALL
CAGES OR BEING TRAPPED AND LEFT.
TO DIE YOU KNOW FOR MANY HOURS
IN THE WILDERNESS -- AND I THINK
THAT WITH THE ANIMALS THAT ARE
RAISED -- IN CAPTIVITY I HAVE
MORE COMFORT LEVEL THAT A LOT OF
THEM ARE BEING RAISED HUMANELY
AND IN KEEPING WITH.
OTHER NATURES THAT THEY DISPLAY
WHERE IS WITH THESE ANIMALS WITH
THESE A PARTICULARLY EXOTIC
FIRST WE HAVE NO REGULATION WE
HAVE NO OVERSIGHT THIS IS MOSTLY
HAPPENED SHE SAID OUT OF STATE
AND OVERSEAS.
AND I DO THINK THAT -- THERE'S A
HIGH PROBABILITY THAT A LOT OF
THESE ANIMALS HAVE SUFFERED IN
PRODUCING THE FOR OKAY SEE ABOUT
DOMESTICATION I MEAN THAT
DOMESTICATION IS AN AGE OLD
PRACTICE RIGHT WE HAVE.
SOME OF OUR MOST LOVING PETS
DOGS ARE DOMESTICATED ANIMALS.
THEY USED TO BE WILD AND YOU
COULD SAY -- WIRE WHY ARE WE
KEEPING THEM INDOORS WITH US SO
WHY ARE WE KEEPING THEM OUT IN A
PEN OUT.
OUTSIDE OR IN THE BACKYARD WE
SHOULD LET THEM ROAM FREE IN
WILD BECAUSE THAT'S SO WRONG I
MEAN THAT'S THE SAME LOGIC.
RED DOMESTICATION IS AN AGE OLD
ACCEPTED PRACTICE.
AND SO NOW THERE ARE GROUPS OR
DOMESTICATING.
THESE ANIMALS YES IT'S IS MAYBE
NEWER BUT THEY'RE DOING THEY ARE
DOMESTICATING THEM HAVE YOU BEEN
TO A FOR FARM.
AND SEEN THAT HOW THESE PEOPLE
ARE RAISING THESE ANIMALS I HAVE
NOT BUT I DO HAVE THAT LEAVES
YOU IN MY DISTRICT AND I CAN
TELL YOU THERE'S A BIG
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN DOMESTICATED
ANIMALS AND THEIR RELATION TO
HUMANS AND THEIR COMFORT BEING.
KEPT IN CAPTIVITY AND ANIMALS
THAT ARE WILD ANIMALS -- AND
THEIR STRESS LEVEL WHEN THEY'RE
KEPT IN CAPTIVITY AND RAISED IN
CAPTIVITY AND THE ANIMALS THAT
WERE TALKING ABOUT -- IT'S BEEN
SHOWN OVER AND OVER AGAIN THAT
THEY DO NOT DO WELL IN CAPTIVITY.
WELL THE MEDICATION IS A PROCESS
RIGHT AND SO THIS IS A PROCESS
IT IS A PROCESS YOU'RE TAKING
ANIMAL MAYBE THAT USED TO BE
WILD AND DOMESTICATED.
AND I WOULD ARGUE THAT WE'VE
DONE THAT VERY SUCCESSFULLY WITH
LOTS OF OTHER ANIMALS.
AND SO I'LL GET BACK TO I MEAN
IS IT IS IT IN HUMANE TO RAISE A
CAL. TO BE SLAUGHTERED FOR ITS
BEEF AND THEN FOR ITS LEATHER IS
IT.
I THINK THE SUPPORTERS OF YOUR
BILL OUT HERE THINK THAT IT IS.
DO YOU ARE YOU ASKING ME I'M
ASKING YOU I WOULD SAY IT REALLY
DEPENDS ON HOW YOU'RE TREATING
THEM WHEN THEY'RE ALIVE IT
EITHER IS OR IT ISN'T IS IT WELL
I I DISAGREE WITH THAT PROMISE
THAT WILL THEN OKAY DIFFERENCE.
LET ME LET ME COUNSELOR ASK YOUR
QUESTIONS AND BATCH OF THE WAY
THANK YOU ECONOMY COUNSELOR THIS
IS NOT A MORE.
I AM AN ACCOUNT RIGHT NOW -- BUT
SEE THE THERE YOU GO YOU SAY IT
DEPENDS ON WHAT HOW THEY'RE
REYES RIGHT OKAY -- WHY DOESN'T
IT DEPEND ON HOW THEY'RE RAISED?
IF THEY'RE BEING REYES.
FOR FOR COULD MAYBE REYES TO
MAINLY FOR FOR AS WELL
[inaudible]
I AM.
I DON'T I I THINK THAT POP
POSSIBLY FOR SOME TYPES OF
ANIMALS BUT FOR MANY NO I DON'T
THINK SO NOT THE WAY THAT THEY
ARE REYES TO MAKE IT ECONOMIC
FOR THEM.
THE WAY THAT THEY HAVE TO KEEP
THE ANIMALS IN SMALL CAGES YOU
KNOW THERE I THINK THAT THAT IS
NOT HUMANE FOR ANY ANIMAL TO BE
KEPT ITS ENTIRE LIFE IN A SMALL
CAGE.
ESPECIALLY WHEN THEY'RE NATURE
IS TO BE WILD I DON'T THINK THAT
THAT IS.
WHAT I WOULD CONSIDER TO BE
HUMANE PRACTICE?
I WOULDN'T EXPECT THAT FROM --
DOMESTICATED ANIMALS EITHER
THAT'S WHY IN CALIFORNIA WE DO
HAVE STANDARDS ABOUT THE ROOM
THAT WE GIVE CHECK INS AND THE
VOTERS ARE VERY CLEAR WHEN THEY
PASSED THAT INITIATIVE THAT THEY
WANTED TO SEE ANIMALS RAISED IN
CALIFORNIA DONE IN A WAY THAT
THEY FELT WAS HUMANE SO I THINK.
OUR VOTERS HAVE AFFIRMED THAT
THAT THEY WOULD YOU WANT THE
STANDARD RATE AND THEY VOTED ON
IT THIS IS NOT THIS IS NOT AN
INITIATIVE BUT WE DO WITH THAT
I'M GLAD YOU BROUGHT THAT UP WE
RAISE CHICKENS IN CAGES.
NOW WE HAVE RULES ABOUT HOW MUCH
SPACE THAT HAS TO BE.
BUT CHICKENS ARE RAISED IN CAGES
IS THAT IT IS THAT IN HUMANE.
YOU KNOW WHAT REALLY DEPENDS ON
THAT LIKE I SAID I BELIEVE THAT
THERE ARE FARM PRACTICES THAT I
WOULD NOT CONSIDER TO BE HUMANE.
AND THEIR FARM PRACTICES THAT
ARE -- BUT I DON'T HAVE ANY
CONFIDENCE THAT AND MUCH VAST
MAJORITY OF FOR FARMS ACROSS THE
WORLD FROM THE EVIDENCE THAT
I'VE SEEN THAT THERE'S MUCH OF
AN ATTEMPT FOR THAT KIND OF
HUMANE.
A RAISING OF ANIMALS.
RIGHT BUT DON'T YOU SEE THAT IF
I PASS YOUR BILL TODAY IF WE
PASS YOUR BILL TODAY THE SAME
LOGIC.
CAN NOW BE APPLIED TO THE CAL
CAN BE APPLIED TO THE CHICKEN
ARE YOU GONNA COME.
NEXT YEAR AND SAY HEY WE SHOULD
BAN ALL RAISING OF CHICKENS
THEIR CELL THAT'S RATHER
SPECULATIVE CAN WE STAY ON THE
TOPIC OF THE UNDERSIDE LIGHTING
I UNDERSTAND THE DISTINCTION
THAT THAT YOU'RE TRYING TO ASK
HERE BUT MS FRIEDMAN AS ALL OF
US HAVE THE ABILITY TO BRING
POLICY.
FORWARD.
IF YOU DON'T WANT TO SUPPORT YOU
DON'T HAVE TO BUT DON'T TRY AND
ARGUE THE BILL IN A DIFFERENT
FORM THAT IS IN FRONT OF US.
MOM TRYING TO ARGUE THE
IMPLICATION OF THIS BILL IS THE
SAME LOGIC.
I MEAN IS WOULD YOU ALSO MAKE
THAT SAME ARGUMENT. FOR A BAND
IN.
ANY CAJUN OF CHICKENS OR VAN AND
YOU DON'T YOU DON'T HAVE.
TO MAKE THAT SAME LOGIC THE BILL
IS BEFORE US IN THIS PARTICULAR
FORM AND ANY SPECULATION ABOUT
WHERE IT MAY LEAD IS MERELY
SPECULATION.
I UNDERSTAND MR GALLAGHER'S
ARGUMENT I DON'T AGREE WITH THE
PREMISE BUT I DO UNDERSTAND HIS
ARGUMENT.
THANK YOU HOW ABOUT HARVESTING
OF WOOL FROM SHEEP.
WE SHARE SHE BETTER THEIR
WALLETS ALLOWABLE UNDER THE BILL
THAT'S ALLOWING WILL YES.
BUT WE'RE IN THAT CASE WE ARE
RAISING THAT.
SHE JUST TO TAKE ITS.
ITS WAR.
RIGHT IS THAT.
UNDER THIS BILL THAT IS A TRUE
STATEMENT.
YES IN THIS BILL WE ARE ABLE TO
USE.
MEET PRODUCING ANIMALS SHEEP
GOATS HOUSE. FOR THE NOT RABBITS.
RIGHT NOW NOT RABBITS WE ARE.
DISCUSSING THAT'S A CONTINUING
DISCUSSION [inaudible]
I'M.
WHAT ABOUT THE IMPLICATIONS FOR
THIS IS A LARGE INDUSTRY I THINK
YOU POINTED THAT OUT IT'S OF
LARGER INDUSTRY?
AS I'VE SALAS LIKE TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY BILLION DOLLARS OF
MANUFACTURED FOR GOODS IN THE
UNITED STATES.
LOTS OF FARMS LOTS OF
MANUFACTURING IF WE GET RID OF
THIS IN BAND ONE OF THE LARGEST
MARKETS IN THE UNITED STATES
CALIFORNIA -- THE REPLACEMENT
WILL BE PHùFOR RIGHT.
WHICH WE KNOW HAS ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPLICATIONS THAT THIS FAUX FUR
AS IT DETERIORATES CREATES MORE
PLASTICS.
IN THE WASTE STREAM WHICH I KNOW
IS SOMETHING THAT YOU CARE A LOT
ABOUT.
I MEAN ARE YOU WORRIED THAT THIS
COULD LEAD TO ALTERNATIVES THAT
ARE PRETTY DAMAGING TO THE
ENVIRONMENT IS ALSO COTTON WOOL
AND I'M WEARING.
WELL RIGHT NOW -- NOT FIRST SO
THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS PEOPLE
CAN WEARS CLOTHING TO KEEP THEM
WARM.
AND THEN THE BILL DOES ALSO
ALLOW -- CAL FOR AND SHE FOR FOR
WHICH A SHEARLING SO IF YOU
REALLY WANT FOR YOU CAN
CERTAINLY USE THOSE PRODUCTS.
RIGHT BUT THE PHùFOR ARE YOU
CONCERNED AT ALL ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT BECAUSE
THIS AS THIS POLICY GOES INTO
EFFECT OTHER.
ALTERNATIVES ARE GONNA COME INTO
THE MARKET PLACE MORE.
YOU HAVE ANY CONCERN ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS OF THAT
FAUX FUR NOW BEING MORE MORE IN
THE MARKETPLACE.
I THINK THAT IT'S YOU KNOW AS AS
SGT SPURRIER'S ARGUMENT THERE'S
A LOT OF DIFFERENT FIBERS THAT
ARE ON THE MARKET THERE'S A LOT
OF TO I'VE SEEN PHùFOR MADE
OUT OF COTTON AND OTHER THINGS
AS WELL -- SO I THINK IT'S YOU
KNOW.
IN GENERAL I AM CONCERNED ABOUT.
POLYESTER AND AND FIBER BUT I
WILL SAY THAT PEOPLE PROBABLY
WASH THEIR COATS A LOT LESS THAN
THEY WASH THEIR YOGA PANTS.
I WAS GONNA WORRY ABOUT ONE I'D
WORRY MORE ABOUT THE MICRO
FIBERS COMING OFF OF CLOTHING
THAT'S WASHED MORE FREQUENTLY.
I DON'T WASH I DON'T HOW OFTEN
YOU WASH YOUR OVERCOATS BUT
PROBABLY NOT THAT OFTEN AND
THAT'S WHEN YOU HAVE A LOT OF
THE THE MICROFIBER ISSUE THAT'S
BEEN MENTIONED [inaudible]
OKAY.
WELL LOOK I I THINK THAT THIS
SHOWS THAT THERE IS A LOT OF
PROBLEMS WITH THIS BILL THAT
WE'RE NOT THINKING ABOUT.
AND I WOULD JUST ENCOURAGE MY
COLLEAGUES LIKE RATHER THAN HAVE
MAYBE.
WHAT MIGHT BE IN A AN INITIAL
EMOTIONAL RESPONSE OUT EVEN I
HAD TO RESPOND MAN WHOSE EVEN
WEARING FOR AT?
I DON'T WEAR IT.
YOU KNOW IT'S NOT SOMETHING YOU
KNOW IT'S NOT SOMETHING I'M VERY
FAMILIAR WITH BUT AS YOU LOOK
INTO THIS LIKE YOU KNOW THERE
ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO DO.
RIGHT AND THERE IS A MARKET
THERE IS A MARKET PLACE OUT
THERE FOR PEOPLE ARE SAYING.
DON'T DON'T USE FOR AND IT'S
WORKING THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE
WHO ARE GOING AWAY FROM THAT.
THE THE MARKET PLACES WORKING
FROM THAT STANDPOINT -- BUT
THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE OUT
THERE AND THERE'S ALSO A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE LEGITIMATELY
FARMING THEY'VE DOMESTICATED.
ANIMALS -- IN A WAY THAT IS THAT
HAS.
AN ACCEPTED PRACTICE AND I THINK
WE SHOULD THINK ABOUT WHAT THE
IMPLICATIONS FOR THAT I DO THINK
THERE'S ALSO A DORMANT COMMERCE
CLAUSE ISSUE IN HERE.
BECAUSE ULTIMATELY WHO ARE WE
AFFECTING WE'RE NOT AFFECTING
OUR OWN PEOPLE WERE AFFECTING
PEOPLE IN OTHER STATES.
WHO ARE A BIG PART OF THIS
INDUSTRY AMHERST AND WE'RE
TAKING COMPLETELY OUT OF THE
MARKET PLACE THEIR ABILITY TO
SELL GOODS INTERSTATE -- THAT
THAT ARE LEGITIMATELY RAISE THAT
ARE HUMANELY RAISED.
THAT ARE USED THAT ARE USING
DOMESTICATION PRACTICES THAT WE
ALL ACTUALLY ACTUALLY HAD THE
BENEFIT OF TO THIS DAY WHEN YOU
EAT BEEF.
YOUR BENEFITING FROM A
DOMESTICATION OF AN ANIMAL THAT
WE RAISE OKAY WE RAISE IT FOR
FOOD WE ALSO RESERVE FOR LEATHER.
WE ALSO RAISE IT FOR A LOT OF
OTHER THINGS -- INTO TO SOMEHOW
LIKE THIS POINT THIS OUT ONE
INDUSTRY.
IT'S GONNA HAVE A HUGE IMPACT ON
THEM WHEN WE DON'T REALLY KNOW A
WHOLE LOT ABOUT IT WE HAVEN'T
TAKEN THE TIME TO HEAR FROM
THOSE FOLKS -- ABOUT HOW IT
IMPACTS THEM ABOUT WHAT THEIR
PRACTICES ACTUALLY ARE THE
AUTHORS NEVER EVEN VISITED A FOR
FARM.
AND YET IS RUNNING A BILL IS
GONNA HAVE A HUGE IMPACT ON THE
SMALL FAMILY OWNED BUSINESSES
THROUGHOUT THE UNITED STATES.
I THINK WE OWE THAT AT LEAST WHO
DOES NOT HAVE A MOTIVE -- YOU
KNOW KNEE JERK RESPONSE TO THIS
ISSUE AND TO TRY AND TAKE CREE
WITH A LITTLE BIT MORE RESPECT A
LITTLE BIT MORE UNDERSTANDING OF
WHAT.
OF OF HOW THIS INDUSTRY WORKS.
I WILL BE VOTING NO [inaudible]
ADDRESS.
THANK YOU AS CHAIR.
THIS FRIEDMAN THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL TO US.
I THINK THE ONE THING I DO AGREE
WITH WITH THIS -- MISTER
GALLAGHER IS THAT OUR FIRST
REACTION IS YES WE'VE GOT TO
STOP THIS IT'S AN INHUMANE
TREATMENT.
OF THE ANIMALS WE'VE GOT TO STOP
IT.
I APPRECIATE YOUR THOUGHTFULNESS
IN SPEAKING WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS IN LOOKING FOR WAYS
WHERE YOU'RE NOT GOING TO
ADVERSELY AFFECT EVERYBODY.
IN FIGURING OUT HOW WE GET TO
WHERE WE WANT TO GO AND THAT'S
TO STOP THE IN HUMANE TREATMENT
OF ANIMALS TO STOP USING THE FOR
AND TO FIGURE OUT.
HOW WHAT THE PROCESS IS TO GET
THERE?
I APPRECIATE ALL OF YOUR
COMMENTS HERE -- THE FACT THAT
YOU HAVEN'T VISITED THE FORM I
UNDERSTAND THAT -- MOST OF THOSE
ARE OUTSIDE CALIFORNIA.
AND YOU MADE A COMMENT EARLIER
ABOUT HOW CALIFORNIA LEADS AND
WE DO LEAD.
AND TO THE VOTERS HAVE TOLD US
HOW TO LEAD IN MANY OCCASIONS
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR LEADERSHIP
ON THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU THIS IS ALSO THE
MISTER.-TO FROM ALL THE BACK AND FORTH I
JUST WANT TO BE REALLY CLEAR.
THIS BILL.
JUST PREVENTS THE SALE OF FOR
CORRECT.
OKAY BECAUSE THAT LINE OF
QUESTIONS THAT WE JUST WENT DOWN
WE COULD GO DOWN IN A COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT FORM BECAUSE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT DOMESTICATED
ANIMALS WELL WHAT IF I WANTED A
FARM OF DOMESTICATED DOGS TO
START EATING AND WEARING.
YOU KNOW THAT'S I'M HOPING THAT
PEOPLE ARE INVOLVED ENOUGH TO
UNDERSTAND WHY THAT WOULDN'T BE
A GOOD IDEA.
AS SOMEBODY WHO HAS EIGHT
PROBABLY SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT VIEW
OF ANIMALS THAN OTHER FOLKS ON
THIS COMMITTEE I DON'T THINK
DOGS BELONG INSIDE I DO HAVE A A
HUGE RESPECT FOR ALL ANIMALS
BEING ABLE.
TO EXERCISE THEIR FREEDOM AND
AND NATURAL STATE.
BUT THAT'S NOT THE SITUATION BY
WHICH WE LIVE IN SO I UNDERSTAND
THAT BUT THIS BILL ONLY HAS TO
DO.
WITH WHETHER WE HAVE EVOLVED
ENOUGH TO DECIDE THAT A CRUEL
TREATMENT OF ANIMAL FOR A
UNNECESSARY PRODUCT.
SOMETHING WE CAN DO WITHOUT THAT
IS IN FACT.
JUST A SYMBOL OF OF DECADENCE.
REALLY IN OUR SOCIETY AND HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH THE NEED TO
KEEP WARM ANYMORE BECAUSE WE
HAVE OTHER IT IT'S EIGHTY
FASHION.
STATEMENT A STATEMENT OF WEALTH
I'M REALLY NOT CONCERNED EIGHT
AT A SPIRAL THAT WE'RE GETTING
INTO AS MAYBE MY A MY COLLEAGUE
I THINK ON THIS QUESTION IT'S
VERY CLEAR I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
I I WANNA YOU KNOW I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT THE BILL IN AND CONTINUE
TO SUPPORT EFFORTS ONE BILL AT A
TIME AS WE BRING THEM FORWARD IF
THEY MAKE SENSE AND NOT GO DOWN
SOME BIZARRE.
DISCUSSION ABOUT DOMESTICATED
ANIMALS AND HOW WE DOMESTICATED
ANIMAL ON WHETHER OR NOT WE
SHOULD EAT DOMESTICATED ANIMALS
BECAUSE I THINK THAT GETS US IN
A DIFFERENT DIRECTION THAT'S
REALLY GROSS.
SO -- AYE AYE AYE.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING US AND I
HOPE WE ARE IN THIS DISCUSSION
SAM [inaudible]
MR.
TO WAS ACTUALLY A MAKE.
PRETTY MUCH THE SAME POINT -- I
DON'T THINK WE NEED TO DEBATE
THIS TOO MUCH LONGER EXCEPT.
THE SUGGESTION THAT
DOMESTICATION SURE WOULD
POTENTIALLY ALLOW FOR THE
JUSTIFICATION OF SKINNING DOGS
OR CATS I DON'T THINK THAT IS
WHAT OUR COLLEAGUE FROM YUBA
CITY I WANT TO SAY THAT.
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THE AUTHOR
OF THIS BILL HAS VISITED A FARM
THAT HAS BEEN INVOLVED IN IN
HUMANE OR CORE PRACTICES DOESN'T
SUGGEST THAT SHE DOESN'T HAVE
THE RIGHT TO PROPOSE THAT WE
BANNED SUCH.
CRUEL AND HUMANE PRACTICES AND I
THINK THAT IS A PERSPECTIVE THAT
I SHARE.
I ALSO WANT TO SAY THAT THERE
HAS BEEN A LOT OF INDICATION OF
THE CONSTITUTION.
TODAY -- ON ARGUMENTS THAT.
DON'T MAKE ANY SENSE WHATSOEVER
LET ME JUST SAY IT'S BEEN
SUGGESTED THAT SOMEHOW WE'RE
VIOLATING DORMANT COMMERCE
CLAUSE.
AND FOR ANYONE WHO ACTUALLY
CARES ABOUT THE CONSTITUTION IF
YOU COULD PLEASE READ THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS BECAUSE
COMMITTEE STAFF TO SPEND AN
AWFUL LOT OF TIME. TO GO THROUGH
WHAT THE COMMERCE CLAUSE DOES OR
DOES NOT DO THIS BILL APPLIES TO
ALL FOR PRODUCTS ORIGINATING
ANYWHERE REGARDLESS OF WHETHER
THEY'RE MANUFACTURED OR REYES
INSIDE OR OUTSIDE THE STATE.
SO THERE IS NO BASIS FOR DORMANT
COMMERCE CLAUSE OBJECTION AND
I'M NOT SURE WHERE THAT WOULD
COME FROM SIMILARLY THE
SUGGESTION THAT THIS BILL WOULD
VIOLATE THE FIRST AMENDMENT
RIGHT TO FREE EXERCISE OF
RELIGION.
AGAIN -- THE BILL LAYS OUT
EXACTLY WHAT THE ARGUMENTS ARE
FOR IT.
WE CAN POTENTIALLY HAVE A
DISPUTE ABOUT IF THE BILL PASSES
A LOOK FOR TO SING THAT
CHALLENGING COURT UP BUT
INVOKING THE AFRICAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY INVOKING.
FIRST AMENDMENT.
IS IS IS TRULY BEYOND WHAT I
THINK.
THE COURTS HAVE SAID IN THIS
AREA ONE FINAL COMMENT I DO HAVE
FOR THE AUTHOR WHICH IS I DO
UNDERSTAND THERE'S A DISCUSSION.
WITH -- THE RABBITS INDUSTRY
ABOUT WHAT TO DO IN THIS AREA MY
UNDERSTANDING IS AT THIS TIME AS
I THINK YOU SAID RABBIT MEAT IS
NOT VERY POPULAR.
SO THE CONCERN IS IF RABBIT FOR
BECOMES REALLY THE SOLE MAJOR
KIND OF FOR THAT'S ALLOWED IN
CALIFORNIA IT WILL POTENTIALLY
DRAMATICALLY INCREASE THE NUMBER
OF RABBITS WERE KILLED AND
INSTEAD OF RABBITS BEING RACE
FOR ME.
THEY COULD BE GRACED FOR FOR
SOME MORE RAISE RABBITS WOULD BE
RAISED FOR SLAUGHTER.
I HAVE TO ADMIT I I I AM VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE POTENTIAL
MINUTES ON THIS I DO HOPE AND I
KNOW YOU WILL.
ABOUT THIS VERY CAREFULLY ABOUT
WHETHER WE WOULD ALLOW A FUTURE
EXEMPTION IN THIS AREA AT THIS
MOMENT I DON'T THINK THAT WOULD
BE SOMETHING I WOULD SUPPORT --
BUT OBVIOUSLY HAPPY TO HAVE MORE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THIS IS A
BILL PROCEEDS ALL THAT BEING
SAID HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
AND IF THERE HAS NOT YET BEEN IN
MOTION HAPPEN TO MAKE THAT
MOTION THERE HAS BEEN A MOTION
AND A SECOND.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU MS FRIEDMAN --
BASED ON THIS CONVERSATION I
LOOK FORWARD TO MISTER GALLAGHER
SUPPORTING OUR EFFORTS.
TO ADDRESS MICRO FIBERS AS A
PLASTIC WASTE AND SAID CLEARLY
SOMETHING THAT YOU'RE INTERESTED
IN A LOT OF US ARE INTEREST IN
THAT TOO SO I LOOK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THEIR AS FAR AS THAT
THEIR CONSTITUTIONAL ANALYSES
AYE I FIND THEM TO BE VERY
CREATIVE.
VERY INTERESTING.
THAT DOES NOT MAKE THEM TRUE NOR
NECESSARILY DISPOSITIVE OF IT
ANYTHING THAT'S BEFORE AS THE
ANALYSIS I THINK LAYS THAT OUT
PRETTY CLEARLY.
MISREAD MENU MAKE CLOTHES I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO THANK
EVERYBODY FOR A VERY ROBUST
DISCUSSION I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE ACTIVISTS WHO TOOK THE TIME
TO COME TODAY TO EXPRESS THEIR
PASSION FOR THIS ISSUE WHEN THEY
WERE COME AND THEIR COMPASSION
AND HUMANITY-- I WOULD LIKE TO
AGREE WITH MR GALLAGHER THAT I
HAVE NOT VISITED A FOR FARM BUT
ONE OF MY WITNESSES HAD AND DID
TELL YOU WHAT HE SAW WITH HIS
OWN EYES AND I DO THINK THAT WE
SHOULD ALL THINK ABOUT THAT.
AND LASTLY I'LL JUST SAY IN
CLOSING THAT MICHAEL KORS AND
GUCCI BOTH.
ATTEMPTED TO GO IN FINE HUMANELY
REYES FOR PRODUCTS TO USE AND
CAME BACK AND SAID THAT AFTER A
THOROUGH EXAMINATION OF FOR
PRODUCTS AROUND THE WORLD THEY
DIDN'T BELIEVE THAT HUMANELY
RAISED FOR EXISTED.
SO -- WITHOUT I WOULD ASK FOR
YOU TO PASS AND I BOUGHT TODAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND THAT MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE BY STONE I
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO CHAO.
CHIU AYE CHIU AYE GONZALEZ.
CONSULT I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA AYE KALRA AYE
FONG.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NO PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS I REYES AYE REYES
AYE.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
THANK YOU LET'S GO BACK TO ITEM
NUMBER TWO MS GONZALEZ AB ONE
SEVENTY LET'S -- I'M SORRY MR
JONES SAWYER IS WAITING
PATIENTLY SO WE NEED TO GO. TO
MISTER JONES SAWYER.
SO ITEM NUMBER SEVEN A. B..
TEN NINETY ONE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE MISTER CHAIR
.
THIS IS JONES SAWYER.
BANK SO YOU HAVE TO BILLS BEFORE
US YES I'M A TAKE TEN NINETY ONE
FOR ANY ONE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
THANK YOU YES AND THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND I THOUGHT
PUBLIC SAFETY WAS REALLY
INTERESTING BUT WELCOME TO
JUDICIARY.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS AB TEN NINETY ONE WOULD
EXTEND AN IMPROVING EXISTING LAW
THAT ALLOWS PARENTS TO SUSPEND
THEIR CHILD SUPPORT PAYMENTS
WHILE THEY ARE INCARCERATED.
UNDER CURRENT CHILD SUPPORT
SYSTEM -- WHEN A PARENT FAILS TO
MAKE A TIMELY CHILD SUPPORT
PAYMENT THAT AMOUNT BECOMES DEBT
IN HIS CHART 210% INTEREST RATE
ONE OF THE HIGHEST IN THE NATION?
INCARCERATED PARENTS MAKE EIGHT
TO NINETY FIVE CENTS AN HOUR.
IN OUR STATE CORRECTIONAL
FACILITIES SINCE MANY CHILD
SUPPORT PAYMENTS THAT
INCARCERATED PARENTS SIMPLY
CANNOT AFFORD IF THE CENTRAL TO
REDUCING RECIDIVISM BY
PREVENTING APPARENT FROM
ACCUMULATING DEBT.
DURING INCARCERATION IS THIS THE
LAW ALLOWS FOR THE SUSPENSION OF
PAYMENTS UPON INCARCERATION
HOWEVER THIS LAW IS SET TO
SUNSET JANUARY.
TWENTY TWENTY AB TEN NINETY WILL
REMOVE THE SENSE THAT THEY TO
MAKE THIS PERMITS PROGRAM
PERMANENT.
THIS BILL ALSO MAKES TO
IMPROVEMENTS TO EXISTING LAW
THAT KNOWLEDGE THE CHALLENGES
FORMALLY INCARCERATED AND YOU
INDIVIDUALS SPACE AND REENTERING
SOCIETY.
FIRST AFTER CONSULTATION WITH
THE CHILD SUPPORT DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION AB TEN NINETY ONE
GIVES PARENTS THREE MONTHS
BEFORE THE CHILD SUPPORT
PAYMENTS RESUME BECAUSE AS WE
KNOW THE FORMALLY INCARCERATED
OFTEN FACE GET DIFFICULTY
FINDING EMPLOYMENT.
IN FACT RESEARCH SHOWS THAT
UNEMPLOYMENT AMONG FORMALLY
INCACERATED PEOPLE HOVERS
AROUND 27%.
AND 60% IN THEIR FIRST.
YEAR POSTS INCARCERATION SECOND
AB TEN NINETY CLARIFIES THAT THE
SUSPENSION OF CHILD SUPPORT
PAYMENTS BEGINS FROM THE FIRST
DAY OF A CAR SERRATION FOR
ELIGIBLE PARENTS.
MEMBERS THIS BILL WAS STRANDED
FAMILIES AND IN CYCLES OF
POVERTY AND INDEBTEDNESS AMONG
PEOPLE WHO ARE RE ENTERING THE
COMMUNITY WITH ME TODAY. TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE
DOCTOR LYNN HANEY PROFESSOR OF
SOCIOLOGY AT NEW YORK UNIVERSITY.
AND ESTEBAN NUNEZ -- WITH THE
ANTI RECIDIVISM.
COALITION.
THANK YOU FIRST WITNESS PLEASE
THANK YOU -- I PRESIDENT HANEY
FROM YORK AND I'M HERE ON YOUR
COAST -- BECAUSE FOR THE PAST
FOUR YEARS I'VE HAD A NATIONAL
SCIENCE FOUNDATION GRANT AND
I'VE BEEN STUDYING THIS
POPULATIONS OF PARENTS WHO ARE
CARS RATED WITH CHILD SUPPORT --
DEBT AND I'VE DONE ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY HUNDREDS OF INTERVIEWS
AND OBSERVED OVER A THOUSAND
CHILD SUPPORT CASES.
AND IN THE WORK I'VE REALLY BEEN
STUNNED BY WHAT'S HAPPENING TO
THIS POPULATION OF PARENTS --
AND REALLY THE LACK OF ATTENTION
TO IT -- PARENTS ACCUMULATE
ENORMOUS CHILD SUPPORT AT WHEN
THEY GO TO PRISON.
IN MY RESEARCH THE AVERAGE
AMOUNT OF DEBT THAT A PRISONER
HAS WHEN HE OR SHE MOSTLY HE IS
RELEASED IS THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS -- THAT'S ABOUT THREE
TIMES THE AVERAGE AMOUNT OF
CHILD SUPPORT DEBT FOR LOW
INCOME PARENTS -- AND IT'S
PRETTY OBVIOUS WHY THIS OCCURS --
WHEN INCARCERATED PARENTS GO TO
PRISON THEY HAVE OR WHEN THEY'RE
IN PRISON THEY HAVE REALLY NO
WAY TO PAY THEIR CHILD SUPPORT
ORDERS -- AS A MEMBERJUST
MENTIONED THEY IF IF THEY GET A
JOB MOST OF THEM ARE --
INVOLUNTARILY UNEMPLOYED BUT IF
THEY DO GET A JOB IT'S ALWAYS
UNDER ABOUT A DOLLAR AN HOUR.
AND THEIR CHILD SUPPORT ORDERS
AVERAGE IN CALIFORNIA ABOUT
THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH.
SO THE DEBT IS IS IS OBVIOUS HOW
WOULD A CRUISE -- AND I ALSO
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT IT HAS THIS THIS SORT OF
PROVING OF DEBT HAS A
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT ON
AFRICAN AMERICAN MEN AND LATINO
MEN.
WHO AS WE KNOW ARE OVER
REPRESENTED AMONG -- IN OUR
PRISON POPULATIONS -- SO WHEN
THEY GET OUT -- PARENTS WHO ARE
FORMALLY INCARCERATED PARENTS --
THE THE EFFECTS REALLY CAN BE
DEVASTATING FOR THEM OF THE
STAFF IT REALLY WAYS THEM DOWN.
IF YOU HAVE THIS KIND OF DEBT
THIRTY SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS YOU
WERE SUBJECTED IN THE IN
CALIFORNIA TO AUTOMATIC
ENFORCEMENT MEASURES LIKE THE
REVOCATION OF YOUR DRIVER'S
LICENSE WHICH THEN MAKES IT HARD
TO FIND EMPLOYMENT.
LAKE MANDATORY WAGE GARNISHMENT
SO IF YOU DO FIND A JOB.
YOUR WAGES ARE ARE GARNISHED --
TO A POINT THAT MAKES IT REALLY
HARD TO MAKE ENDS MEET -- AND
LEANS ON BANK ACCOUNTS AND
PROPERTY THAT ALSO MAKE IT HARD
TO STABILIZE YOUR LIFE AND IN
TURN ALL OF THAT THEN CAN LEAD.
TO RECIDIVISM -- AS PARENTS GO
UNDERGROUND TO AVOID THIS AND
EVEN TO CRIME -- JUST LITERALLY
TO MAKE ENDS MEET AND THEN ALL
OF THIS HAS A REALLY NEGATIVE
TOLL ON CHILDREN THE MIX CO
PARENTING VERY DIFFICULT GIVEN --
THE KIND OF COMBINATION OF OF
GUILT AND PRESSURE THAT PARENTS
FEEL.
SO FROM MY RESEARCH -- THE I'VE
I'VE CONCLUDED THE ONLY WAY TO
STOP THE CYCLE FROM HAPPENING IS
TO STOP THE DEBT FROM ACCRUING
IN THE FIRST PLACE -- AND THAT
WOULD BE A MEASURE LIKE TEN
NINETY ONE SO I SUPPORT IT FULLY
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THAT'S WHAT THIS WITH
CANNOT ESTABA OR NOT I'M NOT MY
NAME IS ROBERT WHEN I AM.
A MEMBER OF A RC I DECIDED TO BE
TODAY BECAUSE THIS SPECIFICALLY
PERSONAL.
AFFECTS ME.
I MYSELF AM A FORMERLY
INCARCERATED INMATE FROM A CDC
ARE ALWAYS INCARCERATED IN TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN I JUST PAROLED
AUGUST THIRTEENTH OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN I DO HAVE ONE
CHILD.
AND I JUST LIKE AS A DOCTOR AND
A SHARE WITH ALL OF YOU.
HAVE WENT THROUGH THESE
TROUBLING THINGS -- WITH TRYING
TO BE A PRODUCTIVE MEMBER OF
SOCIETY BUT BETTER YET A FATHER
TO MY SON.
OF THE LAST FOUR AND A HALF
YEARS MORE CORPORATION IRON RICH
MYSELF IN OVER FIVE HUNDRED
HOURS A SELF HELP.
I SPENT TWO AND A HALF YEARS --
AT CHUCKLE ALL THE FIRE
DEPARTMENT.
OPERATED WITH OVER -- TWENTY
FIVE CERTIFICATIONS -- FROM
STATE FAR TRAINING C. STI THINGS
AS SUCH.
I CAME HOME.
AND I WAS STILL FACED WITH MANY
BARRIERS WITH CHILD SUPPORT I
HAD A FULL TIME JOB.
OF WITHIN FOUR DAYS OF BEING
HOME.
AND MY WAGES AUTOMATICALLY
STARTED ME TOOK AN I CONTACTED
CHILD SUPPORT ON MY CASE WORKER.
WAS REALLY REALLY -- IMPRESSED
THAT I HAVE REACH OUT TO HIM TO
TRY.
TO UTILIZE THEM AS MY BIGGEST
RESOURCE.
I DID HAVE TO FIVE FOR MY
LICENSE BACK I HAD TO PAY
SIGNIFICAN AMOUNT.
BEFORE I WAS INCARCERATED MY SON
WAS ONLY ONE YEARS OLD -- I OWED
A LITTLE BIT OVER SIX HUNDRED
AND SIXTY DOLLARS WHEN I GOT
INCARCERATED I DID FILL OUT THE
PAPERWORK TO WHERE THEY COULD
NOT CHARGE ME MY MONTHLY.
RATE OF CHILD SUPPORT HOWEVER
THE INTEREST THAT WAS
ACCUMULATED OPERATED WITH OVER
THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS OF
OF DEBT.
NOTHING SIGNIFICAN AS THE THIRTY
FIVE THOUSAND HOWEVER I WAS
STILL FACED WITH MANY OF
OBSTACLES.
WITH THAT I'M CURRENTLY NOW.
MY BANK ACCOUNTS HAVE BEEN LEVY
TWICE AND THEY'VE TAKEN
EVERYTHING THAT'S NOT INCLUDING
THE BANK FEES THAT THEY CHARGE
FOR IT LEGAL PROCESSING.
ALSO WITH THAT A MY WAGES ARE
GARNISHED AND ME BEING SEVEN
MONTHS OUT OF PRISON BEING VERY
RESILIENT I HAVEN'T GIVEN UP BUT
THAT MAY NOT BE THE CASE FOR THE
OTHER PEOPLE OUT THERE THAT ARE
GOING THROUGH SIMILAR STRUGGLES.
SO I JUST REALLY ASSET ON THIS
LOOKED AT AND BE LOOKED AT IN
GREAT DETAIL.
AND FOR THOSE THAT ARE REALLY
TRYING TO BECOME PRODUCTIVE
MEMBERS OF SOCIETY AND BE A
GREAT FATHER.
OR MOTHER WHICHEVER WHICHEVER IT
IS THAT THIS JUST BE REALLY
CONSIDER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
IF YOU COME FOR GIVE US YOUR
NAME AND YOUR AFFILIATION PLEASE.
MICHAEL WHAT THE ANSWER IS IT IS
THE COALITION IS STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
YOU CAN LIVE THAT MICROPHONE
JUST LIFTED READY TO BEND DOWN
AT A VERY ON IN YEARS WITH ANTI
RECIDIVISM IN STRONG SUPPORT.
LOUIS BROWN JUNIOR FROM POLICY
LIKE A STRONG SUPPORT.
I'M MY CAROL WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
I SING THAT IS THEIR OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT SIGNAL BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
WAS RIGHT.
I'D LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL NYE I
THANK YOU -- FOR TAKING CARE OF
THE SUNSET I THINK THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IN HUMANE TREAT
TREATMENT IN THE BILL BEFORE
THIS IS IN HUMANE TREATMENT.
AND THIS IS AT A MUCH HIGHER
LEVEL AND TO TO BE ABLE IF WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT SECOND CHANCES OF
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT -- ANTI
RECIDIVISM EVERYTHING THAT WE
LOOK AT IF WE'RE TAKING SOMEBODY
WHO'S COMING OUT AND GIVING THEM
THIS THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLAR
DEBT.
THE MOMENT THEY COME OUT THAT IS
IN HUMANE SO I I'VE MOVED TO THE
RIGHT I'D LIKE TO MOVE THIS BILL
THANK YOU THERE'S A MOTION AS
THEIR SECOND.
AND A SECOND THANK YOU ANY OTHER
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
ALL RIGHT SAY NONE THANK YOU FOR
THIS AND THE NEXT BILL MISTER
JONES SAWYER.
IT IS VERY VERY IMPORTANT THAT
WE MAKE SURE THAT KIDS ARE
SUPPORTED THAT'S WHAT THAT.
THE CHILD SUPPORT SYSTEM IS
ABOUT BUT PART OF THAT IS ALSO
MAKING SURE THAT THERE IS A LONG
TERM RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN.
THE WHO OWES CHILD SUPPORT AND
THAT CHILD AND I OFTENTIMES IF
WE'RE TOO STRICT WHICH SEEMS
LIKE IT FEELS GOOD FOR SOME
REASON TO CONTINUE TO PUNISH.
THEN WE DRIVE PEOPLE AWAY FROM
THOSE RELATIONSHIPS WITH THESE
BILLS ARE ABOUT IS REALLY
STRENGTHENING THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS MAKING SURE THOSE
KIDS ARE SUPPORTED THAT IS
ABSOLUTELY TRUE THOSE KIDS NEED
TO BE SUPPORTED.
BUT WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE SYSTEM ITSELF THIS IS THE
CHILD SUPPORT SYSTEM.
HAS THE ABILITY TO ADDRESS
ISSUES THAT ARE TRUE AND FACTUAL
AND AND ON THE GROUND AND WITH
THESE INDIVIDUALS SO I I THINK
THIS IS A A VERY FIVE BILL AND I
APPRECIATE YOU BRING IT FORWARD.
AND YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU MAY
CHAIR MISTER JENNER SPECTER
ASTRI AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION A SECOND
MOTIONS DO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE BY STONE AYE
GALLAGHER.
CHAU.
CHIU.
CHU AYE GONZALEZ [inaudible]
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA [inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN.
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE I
PETRIE-NORRIS PETRIE-NORRIS I
REYES AYE REYES AYE.
THE BILL NEEDS ONE MORE SO I'M
GONNA PUT IT ON CALL.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT IS AB TEN
NINETY TWO SOME OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU HAVE A MOTION IS THERE
SECONDS.
AND A SECOND THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK.
AGAIN GOOD MORNING CHAIR -- OR
LIKE THAT THANK THE CHAIR AND
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH MY OFFICE.
ON DIE AM GOING TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS I WILL BE
ACCEPTED ACCEPTING THEM TODAY AB
TEN NINETY TWO SUPPORT SUPPORTS
CALIFORNIA POOREST FAMILIES BY
LIMITING THE INTEREST RATE ON
CHILD SUPPORT THAT -- TO THE
STATE UNDER OUR CURRENT CHILD
SUPPORT SYSTEM MOST OF THE MONEY
PAID BY LOW INCOME PARENTS DOES
NOT GO TO THEIR CHILDREN AND
CALIFORNIA FIRST FIFTY DOLLARS A
NON CUSTODIAL PARENTS.
PAYMENTS GO TO A FAMILY TO
SUPPORT THEIR CHILD THE BALANCE
GOES TO THE GOVERNMENT TO REPAY
THE COST OF PUBLIC BENEFITS.
INSTEAD THE MAJORITY OF THE
PAYMENTS GO TO THE GOVERNMENT TO
PAY BACK PUBLIC ASSISTANCE
RECEIVED BY THE FAMILY WHEN A
PARENT FAILS TO MAKE TIMELY
CHILD SUPPORT PAYMENT THEIR CREW
GOVERNMENT THAT NEVER CHARGED
10%.
INTEREST ONE OF THE HIGHEST
CHILD SUPPORT INTEREST IN THE
NATION DATA SHOWS THAT THREE
POINT NINE BILLION.
OF THE STATE'S OUTSTANDING CHILD
SUPPORT DEBT IS UNPAID INTEREST.
FURTHERMORE BECAUSE THIS DEBT IS
OWED TO THE GOVERNMENT LAWS TO
PROTECT AGAINST WAGE GARNISHMENT
DO NOT APPLY.
AB TEN NINETY TWO WERE REQUIRED
TO STAY TO CHARGE ZERO INTEREST
ON CHILD SUPPORT DEBT TO THE
GOVERNMENT THIS BILL WILL HELP.
STOP THE CYCLE OF POVERTY BY
INDEED THE CONTINUAL ASSESSMENT
OF COME ON COLLECTIBLE DEBT THAT
IMPACTS OUR STATE SPORTS FAMILY.
THERE'S SIMPLY NO REASON TO
COLLECT INTEREST FROM.
FORGET -- BY FAMILIES THAT WE
KNOW EXPERIENCING FINANCIAL
HARDSHIP THIS INTEREST DOES
NOTHING TO SUPPORT FAMILIES AND
CHILDREN THE STATED GOAL OF THE
CHILD SUPPORT SYSTEM.
THIS BILL IS A CRITICAL STEPPED
IN POVERTY RECIDIVISM AND
REUNITE FAMILIES WITH ME TODAY
AGAIN.
ON THIS MEASURES DOCTOR LYNN
HANEY PROFESSOR OF SOCIOLOGY AT
NEW YORK UNIVERSITY AND
HOPEFULLY THIS IS LOUIS BROWN
WITH POLICY.
THANK YOU FIRST WITNESS YES SIR
THANK YOU AGAIN -- SO IN THE
RESEARCH THAT I MENTIONED
PREVIOUSLY -- I ACTUALLY LEARNED
THAT -- SO MUCH OF CHILD SUPPORT
IS ACTUALLY REPAYMENT FOR PUBLIC
ASSISTANCE IT'S SOMETHING THAT
PEOPLE UNFAMILIAR WITH THE CHILD
SUPPORT SYSTEM DON'T ACTUALLY
COMPREHEND -- THAT WINS A PARENT.
PAYS BACK CHILD SUPPORT IT.
MORE OFTEN THAN NOT IN
CALIFORNIA GOES TO THE STATE NOT
TO THE PARENTS -- IN FACT IN
CALIFORNIA 60% OF CHILD SUPPORT
AT IS.
PUBLIC ASSISTANCE PAID BACK.
SO IT'S IT'S IT'S MORE THAN A
MAJORITY OF OF THE CHILD SUPPORT
DEBT IS ACTUALLY GO TO THE STATE
THAT BY THE WAY IS THE LARGEST
AMOUNT IN THE UNITED STATES --
AND WHAT'S ALSO. ONE OF THE
HIGHEST IN THE COUNTRY IS -- AS
A MEMBER JUST MENTIONED THAT THE
THE INTEREST RATE THAT'S CHARGED
ON THAT -- 10% INTEREST IN
CALIFORNIA IS A VERY VERY HIGH
END OF WHAT OTHER STATES DO A
MANY MANY STATES DON'T CHARGE
ANY INTEREST.
AND MANY MANY OTHER STATES
CHARGE ABOUT HALF TO ONE THIRD
OF CALIFORNIA CHARGES -- AND THE
RESULT OF THIS INTEREST -- BUT
HIGH INTEREST RATE IS REALLY THE
THIRTY SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS OF
DEBT THAT I THAT I MENTIONED
EARLIER -- OR THE NINE BILLION
DOLLARS OF INTEREST AT THAT IS
OWED TO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA --
BY.
POOR PARENTS BY DEFINITION RIGHT
IF IF YOUR CHILD HAS BEEN ON
PUBLIC ASSISTANCE YOU ARE A POOR
PARENT SO WE'RE ESSENTIALLY
PUTTING NINE BILLION DOLLARS ON
THE BACKS OF OUR I'M SORRY TO
PUT.
NINE ON THE BACKS OF SO IT'S
EIGHTEEN BILLION IS OWED IN
CHILD SUPPORT HALF OF THAT IS
INTERESTS AND HALF OF THE
INTEREST IS FOR PUBLIC
ASSISTANCE SO THE POINT -- WE'RE
BASICALLY PUTTING THAT ON THE
BACKS OF OF POOR FAMILIES.
AND AS HAS BEEN SHOWN REPEATEDLY
THAT IS ESSENTIALLY ON
COLLECTIBLE -- IT'S IN THAT'S
BAD FOR THE STATE TO HAVE THAT
KIND OF ON COLLECTIBLE THAT ON
THE BOOKS -- THE DEPARTED CHILD
SUPPORT SERVICES HAS INFORMED ME
THAT ABOUT 1% OF INTEREST THAT
GETS PAID BACK EVERY YEAR 299%
IS NOT PAID BACK IT JUST
CONTINUES TO A CROW.
WHICH IS BAD FOR THE STATE AND
IT'S ALSO AS YOU CAN IMAGINE
DEVASTATING FOR FOR FAMILIES AND
AND PARENTS.
I DISTRIBUTED THE CHART THAT I
THAT I THAT I'VE CONSTRUCTED TO
SHOW HOW DEBT REALLY SPIRALS OUT
OF CONTROL WHEN YOU CHARGE 10%
INTEREST ON IT AND IT BASICALLY
MAKES IT UNPAYABLE.
UP AT LEAST PEOPLE IN DEBT
FOREVER -- AND THEN THAT'S BAD
FOR OBVIOUSLY FOR PARENTS WHO
HAVE TO DECIDE WHETHER THEY WANT
TO PAY THE STATE BACK OVER THEIR
CHILDREN.
OR THE OR THEIR CHILDREN'S
MOTHERS THE SUPPORT THEY NEED --
AND SO THAT'S BAD FOR MOTHERS
BECAUSE THEY GET REALLY GET LESS
MONEY WITH THIS INTEREST AND
IT'S OF COURSE ALSO MOST
IMPORTANTLY -- BAD FOR CHILDREN --
WHO RECEIVE LESS MONEY AND
ULTIMATELY LESS CARE FROM THERE --
NONCUSTODIAL PARENTS.
SO I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU THAT'S WITH US WITH.
A GOOD MORNING -- CHAIRPERSON
STONE TO MEMBERS OF THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE -- I CAN'T
CONFIRM THAT I AM LUIS BROWN
JUNIOR -- AND I'M ALSO WITH
POLICY LINK WE'RE NATIONAL
ADVOCACY RESEARCH.
RESEARCH AND ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION FOCUSED ON
ADVANCING RACIAL AND ECONOMIC
EQUITY FOR LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES THE COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR.
WE'RE PROUD CO SPONSOR OF AB TO
NINETY TWO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY I
THINK WE ALL AGREE THAT CHILDREN
DESERVE.
OF THE LOVE AND SUPPORT
FINANCIAL AND OTHERWISE OF THEIR
PARENTS -- BUT THE PRACTICE OF
CHARGING 10% COMPOUND INTEREST
ON CHILD SUPPORT THE TO THE GUY --
MEANT UNDERMINES OUR ABILITY TO
ACHIEVE THAT GOAL --
PARTICULARLY FOR CHILDREN WHO
ARE INVOLVED IN THE CHILD
SUPPORT SYSTEM.
MANY OF WHOM ARE OF COLOR IN OUR
SOME OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
RESIDENTS.
AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES SAWYER
STATED A CALIFORNIA CHARGES ONE
OF THE HIGHEST RATES OF INTEREST
ONE CHILD SUPPORT THAT IN THE
COUNTRY.
HIGHER THAN TEXAS HI THE
VIRGINIA HIGHER THAN EVEN
MISSISSIPPI AND CERTAINLY HIGHER
THAN THE STATES THAT DON'T
CHARGE.
INTEREST ON CHILD SUPPORT IT AT
ALL I THINK THAT THE IMPACT OF
THE THE HIGH INTEREST RATE IN
CHILD ON CHILD SUPPORT IT IN
CALIFORNIA.
IS ELUCIDATED BY COMPARING THE
STATE TO OTHERS -- SO FOR
EXAMPLE TWO THOUSAND THREE STUDY
COMMISSIONED BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CHILD SUPPORT.
OF SHOW THAT.
BETWEEN NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX IN.
TWO THOUSAND ONE THE LEVEL OF
CHILD SUPPORT DEBT.
A IN CALIFORNIA A ROSE FROM
AROUND TWO BILLION TO OVER
SIXTEEN BILLION.
AND COMPARE TO NEW YORK.
WHERE IN NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX THE
LEVEL CHILD SUPPORT THAT WAS
ABOUT TWO BILLION IN A ROSE THE
ONLY THREE POINT THREE POINT TWO
BILLION?
AND THE STUDY FOUND THAT THE
DIFFERENCE WAS LARGELY THE
INTEREST CHARGE ON CHILD SUPPORT
DEBT.
SO I WON'T BELABOR THE POINT TO
OTHERS ARE MADE ABOUT WHY THIS
IS A COUNTER PRODUCTIVE.
UP POLICY BUT I WILL SAY A
COUPLE OF THINGS WE KNOW THAT.
AGAIN FROM AT TWO THOUSAND THREE
STUDY.
THAT OVER SEVENTY FIVE SAID
ABOUT 75%.
OF PEOPLE WHO OWE CHILD SUPPORT
DEBT HAD ORDERS THAT WERE MORE
THAN THEY COULD AFFORD IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
IN OVER 70% OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE
CHILD SUPPORT DEBT.
EARN LESS THAN TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR.
SO WE ESSENTIALLY TACKING ON 10%
COMPOUND INTEREST ON PRINCIPLE
THE PEOPLE COULDN'T AFFORD. TO
PAY IN THE FIRST PLACE AT LEAST
A WAGE GARNISHMENT.
SUSPENSION OF DRIVER'S LICENSES
PROFESSIONAL LICENSES WHICH IN
TURN UNDERMINES PEOPLE'S ABILITY
TO EARN AND PAY CHILD SUPPORT.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT THE DEBT THAT
IS PAID IS PAID TO THE
GOVERNMENT MOSTLY AND DOES NOT
GO TO CHILDREN.
IN THE SIM.
CHAIRMAN STONE AS YOU AS YOU
MENTION.
THE INCREASE IN CHILD SUPPORT
DEBT CAN HAVE DELETERIOUS
EFFECTS ON FAMILY RELATIONS AND
RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN PARENTS
AND THEIR CHILDREN.
ARMY CAUSING ESTRANGEMENT.
AND SO OF THAT IS OBVIOUSLY
FUNDAMENTALLY AS YOU SAID AT
ODDS WITH THE SYSTEM THAT IS
SUPPOSED TO BE DESIGNED TO
SUPPORT CHILDREN.
FAMILIES AND PARENTS SO I THINK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND ATTENTION
ESPECIALLY URGE AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
I WAS IN SUPPORT.
IF YOU JUST GIVE US YOUR NAME
AND YOUR AFFILIATION WITH.
MISTER CHAIR MY CAROL WITH THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY A CO SPONSOR THIS
MEASURE IN SUPPORT.
A SPAWNING IS ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION A CO SPONSOR THIS BILL
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
RUBBER WHEN OF ANTI RACISM
COALITION A STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
RIGHT SEEN NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
ALRIGHT SING NONE BIGGER BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
THE MOVE TO TACKLE.
SINCE I WAS IT'S BEEN MOVED THIS
JONES SAWYER YOU MAY CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE BY STONE AYE
GALLAGHER CHAU CHIU GONZALEZ.
CONSULT AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA FONG.
MAIENSCHEIN HI MAIENSCHEIN I
OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE I PETRIE-NORRIS
PETRIE-NORRIS I REYES AYE.
REYES AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER JONES SAWYER
ALL RIGHT MISS GONZALEZ WILL GO
TO ITEM NUMBER THREE AB
.
ONE SEVENTY ONE THIS WAS A BIG
DEAL.
SHE WON ALREADY SHE DID THAT ONE
CHIEF.
SIX SIXTY SHOULD.
SIX OH YEAH.
THANK YOU.
AND I AM.
SINCE THIS COMMITTEE HAS HEARD
THIS BILL BEFORE I'LL TRY TO BE
RATHER BILL BACK.
THANK YOU.
AB MISS CHAIR MEMBERS THIS BILL.
PROBABLY SEEMS FAMILIAR IT'S A
REINTRODUCTION FROM LAST YEAR.
WE WE KNOW THAT A LOT OF WOMEN
DON'T ACTUALLY -- FILE OR OR
REPORT SEXUAL -- HARASSMENT WORK
BECAUSE RETALIATION.
AND THAT RETALIATION COMES IN
FORMED A FEAR OF LOSING THEIR
JOB HERE OF THEIR SHIFT BEING
CHANGED FEAR OF SOMEHOW BEING
REPRIMANDED.
AND WE KNOW IN FACT FROM A FACT
FINDING HEARINGS THAT WE HAD
LAST YEAR THAT THIS HAPPENS MORE
THAN WE'D LIKE TO ADMIT.
THE LAW PROTECTS WOMEN WHO WILL
FILE A LAWSUIT FROM RETALIATION
IT DOES NOT.
PROTECT WOMEN OR MEN WHO SIMPLY --
GO TO THEIR SUPERVISOR AND SAY I
HAVE I I'M BEING HARASSED AND
I'D LIKE IT TO STOP THAT'S WHAT
THIS BILL SEEKS TO DO IT'S A
PRESUMPTION.
A RETALIATION IF AFTER A WOMAN
OR MAN COMES FORWARD AND THEY'RE
THEY'RE FIRED THEIR SHIFT IS
CHANGED WHAT NOT THAT -- THEY IN
FACT ARE BEING RETALIATED SO YOU
WOULD HAVE TO HAVE A ACTUAL
REASON TO AT ARTICULATED REASON
TO TO FIRE OR TO DISCIPLINE
SOMEBODY.
I'M IN THE DAYS FOLLOWING A
CLAIM [inaudible]
STEPPED.
I DON'T KNOW HIS CHERRY.
BY LOOKING AT STAFF YEAH THE
NEXT WITNESS MATTER IMPAIRED
MEMBERS CAITLYN VEGA FOR THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION I'M
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL.
OBVIOUSLY.
THE THREAT OF RETALIATION
SILENCES VICTIMS IT PUNISHES HIS
VICTIMS AGAIN AFTER TAKING THE
RISK OF COMING FORWARD -- BUT IT
ACTUALLY DOES SOMETHING ELSE
THAT DOESN'T GET AS MUCH
ATTENTION AND THAT'S THE
CHILLING EFFECT THAT IT CREATES
ON THE ENTIRE WORK FORCE.
SEXUAL HARASSMENT IS VERY RARELY
A ONE TIME THING WHAT WE FIND
OVER AND OVER AGAIN IS THAT
OFTEN WE HAVE REPEAT OFFENDERS
WE HAVE.
WOMAN AFTER WOMAN AFTER WOMAN
EXPERIENCING THE SAME KINDS OF
CONDITIONS AND IF WORKERS SEE A
WOMAN WHO COMES FORWARD OR A MAN
WHO COMES FORWARD AND TELLS HIS
STORY OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
AND THEN THAT WORKERS PUNISH
THEIR PUT ON THE NIGHT SHIFT
THEY GET HOURS CUT THEY GET
FIRED THAT SENDS A MESSAGE TO
ALL OF THE OTHER WORKERS THAT
THEY ARE NOT.
ALLOWED TO SPEAK OUT AND THAT
SPEAKING OUT WILL BE PUNISHED
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE PASS
THIS MEASURES THAT WORKERS ARE
ABLE TO COME FORWARD AND TELL
THEIR STORIES AND IN DOING SO.
PROTECT THE REST OF THE WORK
FORCE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
REBECCA GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER ONE I THINK
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
INTRODUCING THIS SPELL.
PROTECTS -- WORKERS WHO MAY WORK
LATE AT NIGHT AND ARE ESPECIALLY
VULNERABLE TO THE SEXUAL
HARASSMENT AND WE THINK THIS IS
AN IMPORTANT PROTECTION THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
MILEY'S AT ALL WITH AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF YOUR UNIVERSITY
WOMEN IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
CHRISTINE SMITH CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIPS AND THE REST OF
VIOLENCE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
XIN GUSTIN ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS SAG AFTRA UNITE HERE
THE AMALGAMATED TRANSIT UNION
MACHINISTS AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
RENEE BAYARDO SCA YOU CALIFORNIA
ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TROSZYN BROWN OF THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD YES YOU ARE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
ELECTIONS.
HI GOOD MORNING LOWER CURTIS
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE SAID THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TESTIFY HERE TODAY.
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND THE BUSINESS ASSOCIATIONS --
WITH US ON THIS LETTER ARE
OBVIOUSLY NOT PROPONENTS OF
SEXUAL HARASSMENT WE OBVIOUSLY
TAKE.
BASS SEXUAL HARASSMENT VERY
SERIOUSLY AND THE CONCERN HERE
WITH THIS BILL IS MORE OF THE
LEGAL NATURE OF THE ISSUE IN
THAT IT'S PUT AND MENDING THE
LABOR CODE LABOR CO.
TWO THIRTY RETALIATION IS
ALREADY PROTECTED IN THE
GOVERNMENT CODE IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
HOUSING HIGHLY REGULATE SEXUAL
HARASSMENT IS OUR CONCERN IS IS
THAT NOW THE DEPARTMENT OF FAIR
EMPLOYMENT HOUSING WILL HAVE
THEIR OWN REGULATIONS WILL HAVE
THEIR OWN -- FAQS ON OF AND
ADDITIONALLY THIS WOULD ALLOW
THE LABOR COMMISSIONER TO THE TO
DO THE SAME SOME PLAYERS WOULD
NOT THERE'S NO SAID -- AT
THERE'S NO PRE EMPTION HERE
THERE WOULD BE NO DETERMINATION
WHAT AGENCY ACTUALLY SUPERSEDES
THE OTHER.
SO THEY COULD HAVE REGULATIONS
REGARDING BOTH FOR RETALIATION
UNDER BOTH CODE SECTIONS AND
THAT'S ONE OF THE CONCERNS
ADDITIONALLY THERE'S A
REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION AND WE
UNDERSTAND THAT IT IS A
REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION.
HOWEVER THESE KIND OF SITUATIONS
ARE RIGHT FOR ABUSE IN THAT AND
AN EMPLOYEE CAN ALLEGE THAT THEY
WERE SEXUALLY HARASSED -- BEFORE
A FINDING BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
FAIR EMPLOYMENT HOUSING OR
BEFORE FINDING BY THE COURT AND
LET THEM KNOW THAT THEY ARE
ALLEGEDLY A VICTIM OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT.
AND THEREFORE THERE'S A
REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION -- THAT
THAT EMPLOYEE ANY SORT OF
DISCIPLINARY ACTION TAKEN
AGAINST THAT EMPLOYEE IS BECAUSE
THEY FILED THIS RETIRE BECAUSE
THEY FILED A SEXUAL HARASSMENT
COMPLAINT.
AND THE CONCERN IS IS THAT IT
ALLOWS FOR ABUSE OF THE ISSUE
BECAUSE IN THE CAN FILE THESE
FALSE CLAIMS IN ORDER TO PREVENT
AND I HAVE ACTUALLY SEEN THIS
FIRSTHAND.
AND THAT'S WHY IT'S SUCH A
CONCERN FOR US AND PLAYERS WON'T
BE ABLE TO PREVENT THIS TYPE OF
ABUSE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY AND WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOU BUT NOT ON THE ISSUE.
THANK YOU ANY OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION.
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION ALSO POST
THANK YOU.
JESSE V<c.cyan> WITH THE CIVIL JUST</c>
ASSOCIATION IN CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ANY OTHERS.
LET'S BRING IT BACK. TO THE
MEMBERS ANY MEMBERS HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS.
WAS OUR MOTION.
THANK YOU.
SECOND.
WE HAVE MOTION WE'VE A SECOND
WOULD TO PLEASE TAKE ROLE --
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE MADISON
ELKINS AND WITH THAT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
STONE GALLAGHER CHAU CHIU
GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA.
FONG MAIENSCHEIN HI MAIENSCHEIN
I OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS AYE REYES AYE
REYES AYE.
WE'RE GOING TO LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN WE ARE SHORT [inaudible]
TO THANK YOU.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PRESENT YOUR
NEXT BILL I WOULD THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR.
AT AB ONE SEVENTY ONE MAY ALSO
SEEM FAMILIAR WAS PART OF A A
JOINT THE LAST YEAR WITH THE
RETALIATION -- I WAS COMPELLED
TO REINTRODUCE THIS BILL BECAUSE
PAST YEARS SEXUAL HARASSMENT
WORKPLACE REMAINS A PERVERSE.
PERVASIVE AND PERVERSE ISSUE
ACROSS INDUSTRIES -- THIS IS --
THE WRONG [inaudible]
BILL.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS WE DON'T
READ YOU'RE TALKING POINTS THE
FIRST TIME.
ALL RIGHT.
BUT ALL OF WHAT I SAID WAS IT'S
STILL TRUE -- THE MEDIA MOVEMENT
IS GONE A LONG WAY TO FURTHER
THE DIALOGUE ON HOW TO PROTECT
WORKERS FROM SEXUAL HARASSMENT
WORKPLACE HOWEVER THE
EXPERIENCES WORKERS IN
HOSPITALITY AND SERVICE
INDUSTRIES ARE FAR TOO OFTEN LET
OUT LEFT OUT OF THAT
CONVERSATION.
AB ONE SEVENTY AS PART OF A
PACKAGE OF BILLS TO SEEK TO
PROTECT VULNERABLE LOW WAGE
WORKERS WHO ARE MOST NEEDED
PROTECTION AND YOU JUST HEARD
THE LAST.
ONE THE TRAIN WE'VE SEEN
ESPECIALLY IN JANITORIAL IN
HOTEL HOUSEKEEPING SERVICES HAS
BEEN TOWARD OUTSOURCING WORK TO
STAFFING AGENCIES THESE WORKERS
MAKE WILL GO TO WORK EACH DAY AT
THE SAME LOCATION WEARING THE
UNIFORM OF THE OFFICE OR HOTEL
THEIR CLEANING AND REPORTING TO
MANAGERS ONSITE.
WORKERS ARE IN MANY CASE NOT
AWARE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THIS WOULD
PROVIDE JOINT LIABILITY -- FOR
CONTRACT BUSINESS CONTRACTORS
WHO CONTRACT WITH STAFFING
AGENCIES WHEN IT IS A CONTRACTOR
TO CONTRACTOR SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
AND I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE -- FOR THAT ALL THE
HELP THAT THEY CONTINUE GIVE ME
ON MY BILLS AND I'LL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
IT'S GOING TO BE WITH THE
FIFTEEN BLOOD ADDRESSING.
ANY DIFFERENT THAN.
IN FACT.
I SEE WHAT MUST PART WITH THE
NUMBER FROM SOMEONE AND TAKE
WATER COMMODITY LINK THAT.
IF I'M EVERY THOUGHT AND TRYING
TO BUY LESS BUT WITH CALIFORNIA.
DO NOT THE PROCUREMENT THEY
TRYING IT'S SOMETHING CUT ACROSS
INFLATABLE FOR THE CALIFORNIA.
IT'S BEEN WHAT DID THE
PERFORMERS WOULD YOU PUT THE
OTHER MICROPHONE FRIENDS OF THE
INTERPRETER.
THAT WE COULD TRANSLATE TO AFTER
MAYBE A SENTENCE OR TWO
OTHERWISE YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO
REMEMBER A WHOLE PARAGRAPH.
READY TO FILAMENT THAT THE
MOMENT A SINGLE MOTHER.
WHEN PRINT DELICATE LITTLE THING
THE TOTAL FIFTY SEVEN ANTHONY
THE SMALL THIS CONFLICT ARE
HAVING CHILDREN KEEP UP WITH THE
FIELD WITH?
A ZIPPER WITH SOMEONE WITH A LOT
FOR LEAVE YOUR THOUGHTS OKAY
THOUGHT BY THE COMMENT THAT IS.
CONDUCTING A PROP YOU HAVE THE
BUT BUT THEN THE COMPANION WITH
BUT ONLY IF THE FILM MENTAL
HEALTH.
WHILE WORKING THERE AND HAD A
VERY IS UNCOMFORTABLE
EXPERIENCES.
I FACED THE RISK OF GAS EXPOSING
THEMSELVES TO ME WHEN I WORKED
ALONE IN THEIR ROOMS I WAS ASKED
OUT BY A SUPERVISOR AND I WAS
SUBJECT TO INAPPROPRIATE
COMMENTS.
AND CONDUCT BY MY MALE COWORKERS
ESPECIALLY THE HOUSE.
WHO YOU THOUGHT ABOUT GOING UP
REPORTED NATURAL BY THE COMMENT
YOUR PERFECT BECAUSE LOOK AT A
PHOTOGRAPH I COME OUT I THINK I
MIGHT HAVE?
MISSED AT THE TOP OF THE FIVE IF
I'M NOT THE BUT MICHAEL.
WHO WHOSE JOB IT WAS TO PROVIDE
LINEN AND OTHER ITEMS THAT WE
HOUSEKEEPERS NEEDED TO PERFORM
OUR WORK?
NOTHING GOT A GUY LOVES ME HE ON
YOUTH AND WE DON'T WANT TO
FORGET THE FIELD A FIFTY FAMINE
PICK ON THE LIST THEN YOU GET A
CAT BUT ONLY ONE FEDERAL BUFFEL
SEALED.
AFFECT COME OFF THE HOUSEMAN
WOULD WATCH US WHILE WE CLEANED
ROOMS AND ESPECIALLY WHEN WE
WERE BENDING OVER MY SHOULDER.
WHEN THE FAN COMMENT THAT IT'S
AN APPROPRIATE LOOK MAYBE DOWN
THE FAMILIES?
LEFT WITH FROM THE EVENT THE
FOCAL PILOT NOTHING WHAT THE
IMPROPRIETIES.
THE PHONE TO SAVE ON BATTLE.
A YES THEY THINK ANOTHER WOULD I
GOT MY LOVE MY STATUS IT WILL
PROVIDE.
A FOR MY WALLET.
THEY WOULD COME LIKE A MEDINA
COME BEHIND ME MAKING ABOUT BAD
COMMENTS -- ASKED ME OUT I WOULD
SAY GO AWAY DON'T YOU SEE ON
THAT THE AND I DON'T HAVE TIME
FOR YOU.
THE MAN WOULD LEAVE BUT THEY
WOULD SAY THAT I SHOULDN'T CALL
THEM LATER IF I NEEDED SOMETHING.
IT MADE ME ANGRY TO THINK ABOUT.
THE SUPPORT THE MOTHER MAINTAIN
A HOTEL ANNIKA LOOK COMPLAINING
ABOUT THAT THAT I WORK WITH FROM
THE WITH QUE THEY MONICA THANK
YOU.
GOVERNMENT BLOOD PERCENT THAT
I'M ACT -- BUT FROM A POLITICAL
MUSCLE TO PAY RHETORICAL BUT THE
MOMENT THAT AFFECT AFFECT.
UNFORTUNATELY I'M NOT THE ONLY.
ONE TWO COWORKERS SIGNED UP AS
GALA AND MONEY GOT SANCHEZ WASH
DISHES TEARING AT THEY'VE BOTH
SPOKEN OUT ABOUT HOW THEIR
SUPERVISOR ALLEGEDLY HER AWESOME.
THE QUICKEST ON THE OTHER MOVES
GOOD LUCK WHICH MADE IT
IMPOSSIBLE FOR HER TO TAKE CARE
OF HER KIDS AT NIGHT.
BUT I THE PENDING FEATHER MEET
SOMEBODY MONIQUE I FLEW THOUGHT
DOCUMENT THAT I MET THEM IF THEY
WHEN I CAME TO THE PERFORMANCE.
YOUNGER LOOKED OVER HELLO
LOOKING FOR A PLUMBER HAPPEN
KIND OF THE IN THE CLOSING OF IT
BUT I'M NOT COMPLAINING FLUFFY
BIG BOTH AT THAT ARE NOW.
THERE ARE NOW THE HOOK AND
NOTHING I'M ABLE OF MY LIKE
CONNECT OFFICE AND BUT UNLIKE ME.
SANDRA AND MONICA AND THEIR
SUPERVISOR WORKED AT TURNING AT
THROUGH A STAFFING AGENCY.
AND EVEN THOUGH THE AGENCY
WORKERS WORK EACH DAY AND TENNIS
KITCHENS ALONGSIDE TORNADOES
DIRECT EMPLOYEES.
TERIA SAID THEY HAD NOTHING TO
DO WITH THAT JUST GETS.
THE WICKED FROM THE GOVERNOR
LOVELY THOUGHT PINE ON BROUGHT
TO COURT I THINK THE MOMENT FOR
THE PART FROM THE MENU.
HE FROM INFANT BE A CORRECT
ANSWER.
THEN THE FOR PROFIT.
THEY MONTH OF THAT CONFLICT FROM
YOUR POCKETBOOK BUT CONSTRUCTING
A POPULAR THING TO BUY ME A
AFTER SANDERS SPOKE OUT.
IN TIME MAGAZINE ON AT HER
COURAGE AS ONE OF ITS PEOPLE OF
THE YEAR I FELTTHE COURAGE TO
COME FORWARD.
TO SEVERAL OF US HAVE COME
FORWARD WITH ALLEGATIONS OF
SEXUAL HARASSMENT OTHER SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT.
AT THE TORNADO.
PHONE BOOK RECORD WITH A
MECHANICAL EMPATHY THAT.
SO IT'S THREE THAT THE INCIDENT.
LIKE I MENTIONED SEVERAL OF US
HAVE COME FALL WITH ALLEGATIONS
OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND OTHER
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT ATTORNEY AT
BOTH AGENCY.
AND WORKERS AND DIRECT EMPLOYEES.
WE ALL NEED AB ONE SEVENTY
SANDERS LAW.
BECAUSE WHEN AGENCY WORKERS LIKE
SANDRA CAN HOLD COMPANIES
ACCOUNTABLE FOR SEXUAL
HARASSMENT WE WILL ALL BE SAFER.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS CAITLIN
VEGA FOR THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION NOTHING HERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND THAT THAT YOU'RE
TO MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMISSION GUSMAN ON BEHALF OF
THE TEAMSTERS ABOUT A MINUTE
TRANSIT UNION SAG AFTRA.
AND OTHER UNITS AS WELL AS THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT ALSO WANT TO BE ON
THE RECORD THAT WE ALSO QUICK TO
MY ATTORNEY SUPPORT LAST BILL TO
FORGET SAID [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
RILEY IS A GAL WITH AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF UNIVERSITY WOMEN
SPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
TRISTEN BROWN OF THE FEDERATION
OF TEACHERS ALSO SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD YES HOW THE CALIFORNIA
PLUMMET LAWYERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
RENEE BAYARDO SO YOU
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
.
GOOD MORNING LARA CURTIS ON THE
OF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE THANK YOU AGAIN SO MUCH
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TESTIFIED
TODAY -- AGAIN WE ARE NOT IN ANY
WAY AT PROPONENTS OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT AND DO WE CAN TO CURB
SEXUAL HARASSMENT THAT OCCURS IN
THE WORKPLACE.
NOW OBVIOUSLY VERY SYMPATHETIC
TO THE WITNESS'S TESTIMONY
HOWEVER OUR CONCERNS AGAIN.
ARE THE FACT THAT THESE TYPES OF
PROTECTIONS ARE ALREADY PROVIDED
FOR UNDER THE LAW AND THE
STATUTORY MANDATE THAT THIS BILL
WOULD PRESENT -- WOULD IN THAT
WOULD PRESENT DISRUPT CURRENT
LAW THAT ALREADY PROVIDES
PROTECTION FOR THIRD PARTIES.
IF THE HARASSMENT HAPPENS BY A
HOT BY AN EMPLOYER AND IT'S A BY
A SUPERVISORY EMPLOYEE TO A
THIRD PARTY SO OF THE HARASSMENT
IS BY THE SUPERVISOR.
OF THE THIRD PARTY THERE'S
ALREADY LIABILITY UNDER THE FAIR
EMPLOYMENT HOUSING.
ITS STRICT LIABILITY REGARDLESS
OF KNOWLEDGE IF IT'S BY AND
LOWER SUPER OF NON SUPERVISORY
EMPLOYEE AND IT'S OF A THIRD
PARTY THEN AGAIN ITS LIABILITY
IF THEY KNEW OR SHOULD HAVE
KNOWN -- ADDITIONALLY EVEN IF
IT'S BY A THIRD PARTY THEMSELVES
TO THE EMPLOYEES OF THAT HIRING
ENTITY THEN THERE'S LIABILITY IF
THE HIRING ENTITY KNEW OR SHOULD
HAVE KNOWN THAT THIS THIRD PARTY
WAS -- HARASSING INDIVIDUAL.
EVEN IF.
THE PERSON DOESN'T ACTUALLY FALL
UNDER THIS PERSON PROVIDING
SERVICES PURSUANT TO A CONTRACT.
THEY'RE STILL LIABILITY IF THE
HIRING ENTITY KNEW OR SHOULD
HAVE KNOWN SO WHAT AB ONE
SEVENTY ACTUALLY DOES IS IT
ENCOMPASSES THE SITUATION WHERE
A LABOR CONTRACTOR EMPLOYEE.
ARE HARASSING EACH OTHER BECAUSE
THAT'S WHERE THERE'S NO
LIABILITY OR THERE'S AND THIS
WOULD ASSUME DIRECT LIABILITY
JOINT LIABILITY REGARDLESS OF
KNOWLEDGE REGARDLESS OF ANY SORT
OF CONTROL THAT THE HIRING HD
HAS OVER THE WORKPLACE SITUATION.
AND WOULD IMPOSE DIRECTLY
ABILITY IN THOSE SITUATIONS AND
THAT'S WHERE CONCERN LIES
BECAUSE THEN THE HIRING ENTITY
THE CLIENT EMPLOYER IN THESE
SITUATIONS DOESN'T HAVE THE
ABILITY TO CURTAIL THE
HARASSMENT BECAUSE THEY HAD NO
KNOWLEDGE OF IT.
AND THEY DON'T HAVE CONTROL OVER
THIS THIRD PARTY AND SO IF THERE
IS CONTROL ALREADY UNDER THE LAW
AND IF THERE IS A NEW OR SHOULD
HAVE KNOWN.
AS STANDARD THAN THAT HIRING
ENTITY IS ALREADY GOING TO BE
LIABLE A LAST YEAR GOVERNOR
BROWN VETOED PROVISIONS OF A
BILL THAT WERE PART OF THIS AND
IN HIS VETO MESSAGE HE SAID THIS
BILL CREATES A NEW ILL DEFINED
STANDARD FOR JOINT LIABILITY
BETWEEN LABOR CONTRACTORS AND
CLIENT PLAYERS.
AND THEREFORE AM IS UNNECESSARY
TO THE EXTENT THESE NEW
PROVISIONS ARE ADDED THEY ARE
CONFUSING AND THAT'S WHERE WE
ARE CONCERNED AS WELL WE'RE
CONCERNED THAT THERE IS ALREADY
THE PROTECTIONS PROVIDED UNDER
CURRENT LAW.
AND THAT THE VISIONS ADDED BY
THIS BILL -- SIMPLY AREN'T
NECESSARY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THAT'S WHAT IS NOT.
OF TIME JUST MADAM CHAIR YOUR
BACK MISTER CHAIR SORRY ABOUT
THAT -- CHRISTMAS KAYLEE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
AMBULANCE ASSOCIATION AMONG
OTHER CLIENTS I WANTED.
TO THIS BILL IS PATTERNED AFTER
A BE -- EIGHTEEN NINETY SEVEN
THE HERNANDEZ BILL OF A COUPLE
OF YEARS AGO WHERE WE CREATED
STATUTORY LIABILITY JOINT
EMPLOYER LIABILITY. FOR NON
PAYMENT OF WAGES AND FOR
VERIFICATION OF WORKERS
COMPENSATION COVERAGE.
BOTH OF WHICH I GUESS WE VIEW AS
OBJECTIVELY VERIFIABLE -- ONE
FOR THE CLIENT EMPLOYER TO
DETERMINE QUITE READILY FROM THE
CONTRACTED EMPLOYEES AND AND
THEIR DIRECT EMPLOYER -- THE
ISSUE OF HARASSMENT ON THE OTHER
HAND IS NOT THAT OBJECTIVELY
VERIFIABLE.
SO THAT'S THE FIRST CONCERN WE
HAVE THE SECOND CONCERN IS IS
THAT DESPITE FIAT HAVING.
BOTH NOTICE AND TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS -- UPON EMPLOYERS
THERE IS NO SORT OF GOOD FAITH
DEFENSE FOR LACK OF A BETTER
DESCRIPTION -- I THINK YOUR
COMMITTEE COUNT YOUR COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS IN YOUR COMMITTEE
COUNSEL MISTER CLARK HAS DONE.
A VERY GOOD JOB IN LAYING OUT
THE ARGUMENTS ON BOTH SIDES IN
EXPLAINING.
I THINK THE CASE LAW AND WHAT
ARE THE PARAMETERS OF THE FEE
OUR STATUTE.
I GUESS I WOULD SLIGHTLY
DISAGREE WITH ONE OF THE POINTS
ALL ALL AGREE ON PAGE SIX WITH
THE DESCRIPTION THAT THE PRIMARY
PURPOSE OF FEE HA AFTER ALL.
IS NOT TO ALLOW AN EMPLOYEE
WHO'S BEEN HARASSED TO SUE THE
EMPLOYER.
RATHER ITS PRIMARY PURPOSE IS TO
REQUIRE EMPLOYERS WHEN THEY
LEARN OF THE HARASSMENT TO TAKE
IMMEDIATE AND APPROPRIATE
CORRECTIVE ACTION TO STOP THE
HARASSMENT.
AND PREVENT FURTHER HARM A
STATEMENT WHICH WE WOULD
OBVIOUSLY AGREE TO IT IS THE LAW
BUT I THINK THAT IS THE INTENDED
PURPOSE.
BUT ON THE NEXT PAGE -- THE NODE
IS THAT AB -- ONE SEVENTY WILL
NOT CHANGE ANY LIABILITY THE
PROBLEM IS THAT THE EXPLICIT
LANGUAGE FROM OUR STANDPOINT IN
AB ONE SEVENTY SAYS.
THAT THE KLA CLIENT EMPLOYER
WILL SHARE BOTH RESPONSIBILITY
WHICH SPEAKS TO THE FIRST POINT
BUT ALSO SHARE IN THE CIVIL
LIABILITY.
SO I'D LIKE TO AT LEAST SUGGEST
THAT PERHAPS STARTING WITH THE
FIRST PROVISION IS WHERE WE
SHOULD GO BEFORE IMPOSING
LIABILITY AND THE LAST ITEM THAT
I WOULD RAISE WITH THE COMMITTEE
IS IS THAT THERE ARE SEVERAL
REFERENCES. TO TWENTY EIGHT TEN
POINT THREE AND ONE OF THE
DEFINITIONS THAT IS NOT PICKED
UP.
IN THE CURRENT VERSION OF AB ONE
SEVENTY ALTHOUGH I UNDERSTAND
THERE ARE SOME COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND PERHAPS IT'S IN
THERE.
IS A EIGHTY EIGHTY SIX IN TWENTY
TEN POINT THREE WHICH DEFINES
THE TERM USUAL COURSE OF
BUSINESS BECAUSE IT DEFINES IT
AS A WORK PERFORMED WITHIN OR
UPON THE PREMISES.
OR WORK SITE OF THE CLIENT
EMPLOYER WITHOUT THAT LIMITATION
THEN BOTH THE RESPONSIBILITY AND
THE CIVIL LIABILITY PROPOSED TO
BE IMPOSED BY AB ONE SEVENTY
WOULD GO BEYOND THE PREMISES OF
THE WORK SITE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
YOU GIVE US YOUR NAME AND YOUR
AFFILIATION WITH THE CALL RICE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION WERE ALSO
POSE FOR THE REASONS STATED
THANK YOU.
MATTHEW ARNOLD WESTERN GROWERS
ALSO POST.
JUST PEOPLE A WITH THE CIVIL
JUST SOCIUS IN CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
PRICING NONE BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
MITHRAS.
I JUST WANT TO THANK THE
WITNESSES FOR BEING BRAVE ENOUGH
TO BE HERE WITH THIS GLASS IS
BOTH THE NET A LOT OF ANY LOVE
LOVE MOST.
IF NOT THE GOVERNOR IS A LOCAL
BUS HOSTED.
AT ALL I GUESS THAT I'M.
GONNA SEE IF THAT'S WHAT THE
THANK YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SO I'M
SURE WE ALL SHARE.
YOUR CONCERN.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN WITH MAKING SURE
THAT WE TAKE CARE OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT WORKPLACE I WANTED TO
GIVE YOU THE OPPORTUNITY TO
RESPOND TO A COUPLE OF THE
POINTS OF THE OPPOSITION MADE
WAS I SAW YOU SHAKING YOUR HEAD
IT SOMETIMES AND NOT IN YOUR
HEAD -- IT OTHERS AND SO I CAN
TELL YOU'RE VERY FAMILIAR WITH
THESE ISSUES BUT THEY ARE TECH
ELATED A CONCERN THAT I HAVE AS
WELL WHICH IS THAT -- IT
WOULDN'T BE FAIR TO HOLD AN
EMPLOYER RESPONSIBLE FOR SEXUAL
HARASSMENT THAT THEY HAD NO WAY
OF KNOWING ABOUT AND COULD NOT
OF CONTROLLED EVEN IF THEY HAD
KNOWN ANOTHER WHICH TRANSMIT
THAT OCCURS -- BY PERSONNEL OF
THE LATE OF THE THE CONTRACTED
AGENCY.
OUTSIDE OF THE CONFINES OF THE
WORKPLACE OF COULD YOU ADDRESS
THAT SO -- THAT THERE WAS AN
OVERSIGHT AT AYE AYE.
ACTUALLY AS HE STATED THE A SIX
ON ON SITE OF THE WORK SITE IS
SUPPOSED TO BE WHAT WERE --
WE'VE BEEN CHANGING THE BILL SO
WE WERE REFERENCING THE LABOR
CODE WERE TAKING THE LABOR CODE
NOW PUTTING IN P. HATS VERY.
CONFUSING -- AT THAT'S WHY IT'S
EASIER TO REFERENCE BUT NOBODY
WANTS REFERENCE GOVERNMENT
CALLED FROM FEE HAS SOME TRYING
TO APPEASE ALL SIDES RIGHT IT'S
KINDA LIKE WHACK A MOLE SO WE WE
MISSED THAT ONE PIECE THAT THAT
GOES BACK IN THE BILL THERE'S NO
PROBLEM I DON'T KNOW IF THAT.
SOME OF THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
BUT I I HAVE NO PROBLEM WITH
THAT -- THAT PIECE.
OKAY IT HAS TO BE ON THE WORK
SITE ON OUR SIDE ISN'T THAT
MARKED UP AS PART OF THE BILL
AND I DON'T THINK IT'S PART OF
THE AMENDMENTS THE COMMITTEE IS
OFFERED SO.
UNFORTUNATELY I'VE GOT A VOTE ON
THE DOOR THAT'S BEFORE ME TODAY
AND SO BE IN OPPOSITION BUT
CERTAINLY LOOK FORWARD TO RE
EVALUATING THAT WHEN YOU GET
THAT IN THERE.
I APPRECIATE THAT.
OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND I KNOW WE CONTINUE
TO WORK ON THESE BUT THAT THE
POINT OF THESE IS TO PROTECT.
THAT INDIVIDUALS AND IN THE
EMPLOYEES AND AND WHERE THE
DIFFICULTY BECOMES WERE WHERE
THAT.
EMPLOYER WHO HAS A REALLY SHIP
WITH THE CONTRACTORS WHO HAS
CONTROL OF THE WORK SITE NEED TO
STEP UP AND NEEDS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT THAT SWEPT THAT.
WORK SITE IS SAFE AND THAT THEY
ARE PROTECTION EMPLOYEES REALLY
CANNOT TURN A BLIND EYE.
TO BAD THINGS THAT HAPPEN I
WOULD EVEN ARGUE OFFSITE
DEPENDING ON WHAT THE
EXPECTATION IS FOR THAT EMPLOYEE
AND IF THEY HAVE TO BE WORKING
OFF SITE.
AND THEY ARE THEN THE VICTIM SO
IT AYE IT'S NOT QUITE TO ME AS
EASY AS THAT AND I KNOW YOU YOU
WANT TO DRESS AT AND YOU CAN
MOVE THAT BOARD.
BUT I JUST WANT TO DRAW THAT
DISTINCTION.
WHERE AN EMPLOYER HAS A RELATION
HAS HAS HIRED INDOORS BRINGING
IN A CONTRACTOR AND ONE OF THEIR
EMPLOYEES?
IS BEING HARASSED THE COMMON
DENOMINATOR THEIR ULTIMATELY IS
THE EMPLOYER WHO HAS THE ABILITY.
IF THEY KNOW ABOUT THE PROBLEM.
TO ADDRESS THE PROBLEM BOTH
CONTRACTUALLY WITH THE
CONTRACTOR BUT ALSO TAKE CARE OF
THE EMPLOYEE SO TO ME.
JUST.
WE STILL NEED TO BE CAREFUL THAT
WE ARE PROTECTING EMPLOYEES WHO
WANT TO FEEL SAFE IN THEIR
WORKPLACE AND I KNOW THAT'S THE
THE GOAL OF THE BILL SO I
APPRECIATE THAT.
IT WAS ALSO A CLOSE THANK YOU
AND I'M JUST I I THINK TO
CLARIFY WHY THIS BILL IS COMING
ABOUT AND TO UNDERSTAND THE
FACTS SITUATION.
OF AND WHY WE CALLED SANDERS LAW
QUITE QUITE FRANKLY AND IN THIS
RESORT IN A LOT OF EMPLOYERS ARE
ARE ARE THEY'VE GONE FROM NOT
ONLY.
CONTRACTING IN -- RANK AND FILE
EMPLOYEES BUT ALSO TO THE
SUPERVISOR FOR THOSE RANK AND
FILE FILE FILE PLAYS AND SO WHEN
THE WORKER WHO'S SUPERVISORS
HARASSING THEM AND DOESN'T
UNDERSTAND THE RELATIONSHIP THAT
THERE AND THEY THINK THEY WORK
FOR THE THE RESORT.
GOES TO THE RESORT SAYS I'M
BEING -- SEXUALLY HARASSED BY MY
SUPERVISOR AND LITERALLY IN THIS
CASE THE RESORT SAID THAT'S NOT
OUR PROBLEM THAT'S YOUR
SUPERVISOR FROM SO THE WORKER
HAS NO WHERE TO GO -- THE THE
EMPLOYER THE MASTER EMPLOYER
KNEW ABOUT THE SITUATION HAD NO.
OBLIGATION TO REMEDY HAD NO
OBLIGATION -- TO TO TO DO
ANYTHING IT IS A PIECE OF OF THE
STATUTES IT'S MISSING NOW YES IF
THERE'S A IF YOU'RE SUPERVISOR
AND THERE'S AN OUTSIDE PERSON IF
YOU'RE AN EMPLOYEE TO A CONTRACT
OF YOUR CONTRACTOR TO AN
EMPLOYEE WELL.
WHAT ABOUT A CONTRACTOR
CONTRACTOR THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO FIX I FEEL LIKE I'VE
BEEN PLAYING WHACK A MOLE WITH
THE CHAMBER AND -- FOLKS ON THIS
FOR TWO YEARS NOW AND IF YOU'D
LIKE TO GIVE ME LANGUAGE ON THAT
THEY THINK CLARIFIES WHAT I'M
TRYING TO DO WHICH IS AT SHOULD.
I THINK WE ALL AS THEY WOULD
SUGGEST SHOULD ALREADY BE IN LAW
THEY THINK IT'S ALREADY LOTS NOT --
BUT IF THERE'S LANGUAGE THAT
HELPS THEM FEEL LIKE I'M NOT
GOING FURTHER THAN THE LOT.
AS IT SHOULD BE I'D BE HAPPY TO
TAKE THAT I'M HAPPY TO TAKE TO
TO CHANGE -- AND ENSURE AYE AYE
I AGREE WITH THE CHAIRMAN THAT
THERE ARE PROBABLY SITUATIONS
I'M NOT THINKING OF THAT ARE OFF
THE SIDE OF THE WORKPLACE BUT
WE'RE TRYING TO DEAL WITH A VERY
SPECIFIC ISSUE.
THAT HAPPENS -- IN JANITORIAL IN
PARTICULAR AND AT IN RESORT
HOTEL WORK -- AND WE KNOW ABOUT
WORKING AND WE WE WANT TO
PROTECT WORKERS SO I'M GETTING A
LITTLE FRUSTRATED -- BECAUSE
THIS IS TWO YEARS OF LITERALLY
MOVING THAT'S FROM CODE A CODE
AND CHANGING ONE WORD OR
CHANGING TWO WORDS TO TRY TO
SATISFY.
AN OPPOSITION THAT'S NEVER GOING
TO BE SATISFIED AND SO -- WITH
THAT ALL I ASK IS THAT WE
ACTUALLY TRY TO PROTECT WORKERS
AND SO I ANSWERED MY BY.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND THE MOTION IS DO
PASS AS AMENDED CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE AYE STONE AYE
GALLAGHER.
BUT CHAO.
CHU.
CHU AYE GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ I
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA.
FONG.
FONG NO MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I OBERNOLTE
OBERNOLTE NO PETRIE-NORRIS
RADIUS.
HI RES I THAT BILL IS ON CALL IT
NEEDS ONE MORE.
ALRIGHT MR HOLDEN.
THAT BRINGS US TO ITEM OUR ITEM
NUMBER.
FIVE AB SIX SIXTY NINE AND I
WILL KNOW BECAUSE I DON'T THINK
I DID THAT ITEM NUMBER SIX A. B.
SEVEN NINETY FIVE IRWIN.
WAS PULLED FROM OUR AGENDA BY
THE AUTHOR.
PROBLEMS WITH THE BILL.
THERE IS A MOTION IS THERE A
SECOND [inaudible]
MR HOLDEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
PHIL HONOR TO PRESENT THE MOST
HIGHLY ANTICIPATED TILL THE
MORNING.
THE ONE CURRENTLY BEFORE US IS
ALWAYS THE MOST WORK THOUGH.
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I AM PROUD TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL SIX SIXTY
NINE A BILL THAT AUTHORIZES THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO USE A TYPE
OF SADDAM A TOOL CALLED.
AN ASSURANCE OF VOLUNTARY
COMPLIANCE OR ABC FOR SHORT.
AND MULTISTATE CASES INVOLVING
CALIFORNIA OTHER STATES OUR
SISTER STATES COMMONLY USE A. B.
C.'S TO SETTLE WITH DEFENDANTS
OFTEN AND CONSUMER PROTECTION OR
ENVIRONMENTAL.
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS.
THE ABC.
A. B. C.'S ARE GENERALLY
ENFORCEABLE BY THE COURTS.
UNDER THOSE STATE STATES ABC
STATUTES.
IN CALIFORNIA HOWEVER THERE IS
NO EXPRESS LEGAL AUTHORITY IN
CALIFORNIA LAW FOR THIS AG TO
ENTER INTO AN ABC THAT IS A
FORCIBLE BY THE COURT.
IF THE FIT THE DEFENDANT.
NOT COMPLY WITH THE TERMS OF THE
SETTLEMENT.
WITH A LIMITED EXCEPTION OF
TERRIBLE TRUST CASES.
THIS BILL WOULD REMAIN THAT GAP
AND ALLOW THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
TO ENTER INTO A. B. C.'S.
AND CONSUMER PROTECTION AND
OTHER NON SECURITY RELATED CASES
THAT ARE ENFORCEABLE THROUGH THE
COURTS.
UNDER THIS BILL A. B. C.'S ARE
JUST AS STRONG AS STIPULATED
JUDGMENTS AND CAN BE ENFORCED IN
THE SAME WAY.
SB SIX SIXTY NINE WILL HELP
STREAMLINE SETTLEMENTS AND
MULTISTATE CASES AND PREVENT
UNNECESSARY LITIGATION COSTS
THUS ENSURING MORE EFFICIENT USE
OF DOJ RESOURCES.
THIS BILL SPONSORED BY THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF YOUR FOR
SERRA AND HAS NO KNOWN
OPPOSITION AND FOR THESE REASONS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
AND JOINING ME TODAY IS --
ANTHONY LOU FROM DOJ TO TESTIFY
ABOUT THE BILL.
THANK YOU ALTHOUGH I AM INTENDED
TO CREATE A NEW RULE THAT SAYS
FORMER STAFF MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE WHO LEFT US IN THE
LURCH TO GO OFF TO GREENER
PASTURES MAY NOT BE ABLE TO
TESTIFY WELL -- KNOWN THAT'S
REPRESENTING THE AG MISTER.
YES HELLO -- WE WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN FOR
PARTNERING WITH US ON THIS BILL.
TO PROVIDE THE AG WITH AN
IMPORTANT TOOL IN THE TOOLBOX.
THE ABC.
AND TO INCREASE EFFICIENCIES
WHILE ENHANCING ENFORCEMENT
ABILITIES.
AND WE WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE CONSULTANT FOR THE
THOROUGH ANALYSIS OF THE BILL --
BY BRADLEY AUTHORIZING THE USE
OF A. B. C.'S IN CALIFORNIA.
THE BILL GIVES THE AG THE
ABILITY TO USE A TOOL THAT CAN
BE PARTICULARLY HELPFUL IN
FACILITATING SETTLEMENTS AND
MULTISTATE CASES.
WHERE OUR SISTER STATES ARE
ALREADY USING A. B. C.'S TO DO
SO?
AS THE COMMITTEE ANNOUNCES POINT
SATIN PAGE FOR ABC'S CAN SAVE
TIME AND RESOURCES.
I WOULD OTHERWISE BE CONSUMED IN
NEGOTIATING A STIPULATED
JUDGMENT.
OR IN LITIGATION F. -- SUCH
NEGOTIATIONS ARE UNSUCCESSFUL.
IN ADDITION INCREASING
EFFICIENCIES FOR THE DEPARTMENT
THIS BILL HELPS ENSURE THAT.
FROM AN ENFORCEMENT PERSPECTIVE
CALIFORNIANS ARE JUST AS
PROTECTED AND WELL SITUATED AS
RESIDENTS OF OUR SISTER STATES
IF AND WHEN THE AG.
ELECTS TO ENTER INTO AN ABC.
SO WE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I'VE.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MR HOLDEN YOU MAY CLOSE.
I THANK YOU RESEARCHER -- I'M
HAPPY THAT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
IS CONTINUE TO LOOK AT WAYS TO
CREATE EFFICIENCIES AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR ABOUT.
THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A MOTION A SECOND MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE STONE BY
STONE AYE GALLAGHER.
CHAO [inaudible]
CHIU.
CHIU AYE GONZALEZ.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA [inaudible]
FONG.
MAIENSCHEIN I MAIENSCHEIN I
OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE I PETRIE-NORRIS REYES.
THAT BILL IS ON CALL IT NEEDS A
COUPLE MORE VOTES MR HOLDEN
[inaudible]
SO. FOR THOSE MEMBERS LET'S ROLL
THROUGH THE AGENDA MAKE SURE WE
CATCH EVERYONE HERE AND IF WE
COULD CALL.
OTHER MEMBERS I'M GOING TO LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR A LITTLE WHILE
AND HOPEFULLY WE GET OTHER
MEMBERS BACK SO WE CAN COULD
CONCLUDE OUR BUSINESS FOR TODAY.
SO WE'RE GONNA START WITH THE
CONSENT AGENDA CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS PLEASE.
GALLAGHER CHIU.
YOU AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I FONG.
FONG I REYES.
OKAY LET'S JUST GO THROUGH IN
ORDER ITEM NUMBER ONE AB FORTY
FOUR FRIEDMAN CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS CHAO [inaudible]
FONG.
LET'S SEE ITEM NUMBER WELL IT'S
HIS GIVES AT ITEM NUMBER TWO
WHICH IS ON CALL IN A LIFT THE
CALL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. TO
HAVE NOBODY'S HERE FOR THAT SO
REPLACE THE CALL ITEM NUMBER.
THREE HI MELISSA CALL AN ITEM
NUMBER THREE AB ONE SEVENTY ONE
GONZALEZ CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
STONE BY STONE AYE GALLAGHER.
CHAU.
CHIU.
CHIU AYE KALRA.
FONG.
FONG NO OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NOW.
THAT BILL IS OUT THIS ITEM
NUMBER FOUR AB SIX SIXTY EIGHT
GONZALEZ CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
GALLAGHER CHU.
CHU AYE.
REYES.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE IS ON CALL.
I DON'T THINK WE'VE YEAH I'M
GONNA LIFT THE CALL AND ITEM
NUMBER.
FIVE AB SIX SIXTY NINE HOLE THAT
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
GALLAGHER.
CHAU.
CHAO AYE GONZALEZ.
KALRA [inaudible]
NORRIS REYES.
OKAY THAT'S STILL NEEDS ONE MORE
SO I'M GOING TO REPLACE THE CALL.
I REMEMBER SIX WAS PULLED FROM
THE DEAD ITEM NUMBER SEVEN IS ON
CALL THAT IS AB ONE OH NINE
JONES OR MIDDLE IF THE CALL CALL
THE UPS MEMBERS.
GALLAGHER CHOW.
CHOW I AND SALAS [inaudible]
KALRA [inaudible]
FONG.
FONG I MAIENSCHEIN MAIN CHINA.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
ITEM NUMBER.
EIGHT HAS PASSED THE COMMITTEE
BUT I'M GOING.
TO ALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS THIS
IS AB TEN NINETY TWO JONES
SAWYER.
CALL THE OF THE MEMBERS
GALLAGHER.
NO GALLAGHER NO CHOW.
CHAO AYE CHU.
CHU AYE KALRA [inaudible]
FONG.
OKAY THE BILL YET THAT BILLS
ALREADY OUT SO WE STILL HAVE TO
BILLS PHONE CALL.
IF WE COULD GET MEMBERS WHO HAVE
NOT VOTED LET'S GO THROUGH THE
LIST AGAIN [inaudible]
CONSENT.
GALLAGHER HI GALLAGHER I REYES.
HE'S ON ONE ALREADY BUT
CHALLENGE.
OKAY ITEM NUMBER ONE AB FORTY
FOUR FRIEDMAN CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS CHOW.
CHOW I ITEM NUMBER.
TWO IS ON CALL AB ONE SEVENTY
GONZALEZ I'M GONNA LIFT THE CALL
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO CHOW.
CHOW I KALRA [inaudible]
PETRIE-NORRIS.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
ITEM NUMBER THREE AB ONE SEVENTY
ONE GONZALEZ CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS GALLAGHER.
CHOW.
CHOW I KALRA.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB SIX SIXTY
EIGHT GONZALEZ CALLED ABSENT
MEMBERS GALLAGHER.
REYES.
I REYES I KNOW.
GALLAGHER NO.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT IS ON CALL A
THIS IS AB SIX SIXTY NINE HOLDEN
I'M GOING TO LIFT THE CALL.
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
GONZALEZ [inaudible]
KALRA [inaudible]
PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS AYE REYES AYE
REYES AYE.
OKAY THAT BILL IS OT.
ITEM NUMBER SIX IS PULLED ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN AB ONE OH NINE
JONES SAWYER CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
GALLAGHER -- CAN [inaudible]
GONZALEZ [inaudible]
KALRA.
AND ITEM NUMBER EIGHT A. B. TEN
NINETY TWO JONES SAWYER CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS KALRA.
OKAY SO WE NEED.
CONSENT [inaudible]
CONSENT.
WE HAVE SOME MEMBERS ON
CONSENSUS HI HI.
OKAY YEAH.
ONE SO WE NEED A COUPLE MEMBERS
TO COME BACK TO COMMITTEE SO WE
CAN FINISH OF OUR BUSINESS
.
SO ITEM FIVE SIX SIXTY NINE
HOLDEN.
I'M GONNA GO FROM NOT VOTING TO
AYE.
FONG NOT VOTING DIE.
RIGHT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
A RIGHTS.
SO WE KNOW YOU'RE MISSING ON
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT HOLDEN AB.
SIX SIXTY NINE OF THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
WE HAVE.
FIND.
HOLDEN THE WHOLE THE BILL ITEM
NUMBER IF I'M SORRY I MISS READ
ITEM NUMBER FIVE EIGHTY SIX SIX
NINE GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I KALRA.
AND FEDERAL PERCENT AND
SEVEN
OKAY.
SO WE'RE GONNA CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ITEM TO WHICH IS AB ONE
SEVENTY GONZALEZ CALL THE
OBSERVERS KALRA.
COLORI.
ITEM THREE AB ONE SEVENTY SEVEN
GONZALEZ KALRA [inaudible]
KALRA AYE.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB SIX SIX NINE
HOLDEN.
KALRA [inaudible]
CALL RIGHT.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN A. B. TEN
NINETY ONE JONES SAWYER KALRA.
KALRA AYE.
ADD ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB TEN
NINETY TWO JONES SAWYER KALRA.
KALRA.
AND THAT COMPLETES OUR BUSINESS
FOR TODAY WE ARE ADJOURNED